Uns.
Ich bin ein sehr guter Mensch, aber ich bin auch ein sehr guter Mensch.
Schön guten Abend, hier ist Chaosradio 91 in Blumenau-Fritz. Unser Thema heute das Web als Nachschlagewerk im Studio Tim Pritloff. Kurt Jansson von der Wikipedia und Fidel, weil er nix besseres zu tun hatte, oder? Ihr könnt ruhig sprechen, das ist Hörfunk, wenn ihr dann nickt, dann nutzt das wenig. Tim, guten Abend. Guten Abend, Fidel. Guten Abend. Guten Abend, Kurt.
Hallo, ich bin auch da.
Hallo, Tim, das freut mich, dass du auch hier gekommen bist.
Ich kämpfst nur noch ein bisschen mit den Tools. Die Tools? Ja, die Tools. Mit was?
Mit Z. Ja sicher, Tools Rulay.
Vom Doppel-Null.
An den Knöpfen Holger Klein, in Vertretung für Max von Malotki, der hatte was besseres zu tun. Ich glaube, sich die Nase putzen oder so.
Krank rumliegen auf seiner Freundin. Das ist eine gute Besserung.
Ja, und gesagt ist gesagt, gewählt ist gewählt.
Ja, gerne. Chaosradio 91 und dieses Mal dreht es sich um das Web. Und zwar das Web in seiner Funktion als Nachschlagewerk für Jedermann. Mit dem Schwerpunkt auf freien Nachschlagewerken, also die, die von jedem, ohne jetzt dafür zu bezahlen, verwendet werden können. Derer gibt es doch eine ganze Menge.
Der Plattelsmann. Was denn?
Hast du gesagt.
Ja, aber nur per WAP. Das ist das Einzige, was ich bei WAP nützlich finde.
Auch das noch.
Und einen besonderen Schwerpunkt wollen wir heute legen, ob die Wikipedia, die eins der besonderen Nachschlagewerke im Netz ist, und warum das so besonders ist, das werden wir dann ausführlich erörtern.
Ja, das war's schon.
Ja, das war schon mal das Thema der Sendung.
Verblüffend, wie schnell du heute auf den Punkt kommst.
Benutzst du denn das Web als Nachschlagewerk?
Im Internet steht ja alles. Das schlage ich dann nach und lande meistens bei Ebay.
Ja, ich meine, wenn man über Google nachschlägt, dann kommt man schon relativ häufig bei Ebay raus. Google auch kräftig zu kämpfen hat mit einer ganzen Menge und weniger Organisationen, die sich sehr darum bemühen mit Linkfarmen und ähnlichen Methoden, die Suchworte, nach denen die Leute halt so suchen, auf ihre Seiten zu lenken, unter anderem eben auch auf Ebay Seiten. Das ist da recht populär, um halt irgendwas an den Mann zu bringen. Google macht da eigentlich ja wohl schon einen ganz guten Job, das zu verhindern, aber es ist natürlich schon ein inhärentes Problem von Suchmaschinen an sich, dass sie es einfach schwer haben, das Relevante wirklich rauszufinden. Und nicht selten ist der Bedarf des Suchenden ja der, dass man etwas erklärt bekommen möchte. Also klar, man möchte auch manche Prädomis finden oder so, aber man möchte halt manchmal auch einfach was erklärt bekommen, möchte gerne wissen, worum geht es denn hier eigentlich. Und dann zeigt sich immer wieder, dass Suchmaschinen, egal ob das nun Google oder irgendeine der anderen Suchmaschinen, All the Webben, wie sie alle heißen, ist, dass es einfach nicht unbedingt der richtige Ansatz ist, das zu machen. Und ein sehr guter Ansatz, sich eine Erklärung für irgendetwas herauszufinden, ist zum Beispiel die Wikipedia, die als Online Encyclopädie einerseits jedermann offensteht, und die auch klar den Auftrag hat, zu Begriffe zu vermitteln, Begriffe zu erklären und eben auch eben die Möglichkeit zu geben, selber zur Begriffsklärung beizutragen.
Lass uns doch einfach mal die Frage, die du mir gestellt hast, an die Hörenden weitergeben. Also abgesehen von Suchmaschinen, um irgendetwas zu finden, wo schlagt ihr denn im Web nach, wenn ihr irgendetwas finden wollt? Also eine Erklärung zu irgendeinem Sachverhalt oder zu irgendeinem Wort. 0331 70 97 110. Also wo schlagt ihr nach? Würde uns mal interessieren im Chaosradio. Chaosradio 91 auf Fritz, das Web als Nachschlagewerk ist unser Thema heute Abend. Die Frage an euch Höhende, wo schlagt ihr denn nach, wenn ihr irgendwelche Informationen haben wollt? Die Frage lautet nicht unbedingt, welche Suchmaschine benutzt ihr am liebsten, sondern wo schlagt ihr nach? Also in welcher Enzyklopädie? In welchem Lexikon? 0331 70 97 110. Hallo Christoph.
Ich schlage also meistens bei Google nach und da lande ich halt auch auf Enzyklopäden wie Wikipedia. Das Wichtige beim Nachschlagen meiner Ansicht nach ist, dass man die richtigen Suchbegriffe verwendet und dann kommt man eigentlich auf die richtigen Seiten.
Aber das ist doch genau das, was ich als, ich sag mal, als einfacher, stinknormaler, dümmste anzunehmender User nicht möchte, mich damit auseinandersetzen, welche Suchbegriffe ich vernünftigerweise verwende.
Na gut, aber man hat ja im Prinzip ein Thema, wonach man im Prinzip suchen will und man hat meistens das Problem, dass die Suchergebnisse viel zu viele sind, dass das im Bereich von 1000 oder 10.000 liegt. Und die gesuchten Informationen eigentlich in denen untergehen, sozusagen, die man eigentlich haben will. Und was ich halt festgestellt habe, wenn ich mich mit Leuten unterhalte, dass die meisten nicht wissen, dass man auch nach ganzen Wortketten suchen kann, indem man das Ganze einfach in Anführungsstrichen setzt.
Das steht aber in der Bedienungsanleitung. Also ich hab das ja mal gelesen.
Ja, die meisten wissen es trotzdem nicht. Und dann kommt man halt auf Wikipedia oder ähnliches.
Alles klar, vielen Dank Christoph. Und gute Nacht, tschüss. Und hallo Jonathanus Treptow. Wo schlägst du nach?
Also ich geh ja halt auch meistens über Google und komm dann aber halt auch oft zur Wikipedia. So zum Beispiel heute früh, als ich nach einer ordentlichen Erklärung fürs Brutto-Sozialprodukt gesucht habe.
Ach, da hättest du anrufen können. Das weiß ich sogar noch auswendig von damals. Das glaub ich.
Und wer ist denn zufriedenstellender?
Mit dem Unterschied zum Brutto-Inlandsprodukt.
Mit dem Unterschied zum Brutto-Inlandsprodukt und dem Unterschied zum Brutto-Inländerprodukt. Das gibt's nämlich auch noch.
Ja, na das ist ja dann wohl ungefähr das Brutto-Sozialprodukt, wenn ich's richtig verstanden habe.
Das Brutto-Inländerprodukt ist im Grunde genommen das Brutto-Sozialprodukt, ja.
Na, jedenfalls, wenn ich dann über Google direkt erstmal nichts finde, mach ich halt immer noch irgendwie oft den Fehler und geh zu Endkater. Weil Endkater fand ich früher auf jeden Fall gut, aber wenn ich jetzt bei Endkater was suche, sind immer die ersten fünf Themen, die er anzeigt und die halt dann wahrscheinlich am nächsten da ranliegen, sind halt immer kostenpflichtig. Also da überlege ich mir jetzt manchmal, ob man da dann vielleicht schon so rangehen muss, dass man das so trifft, dass man dann das sechste Thema oder so in Hell ist der erste, damit es nicht mehr so kostenpflichtig ist. Aber irgendwie wundert es mich halt ein bisschen so.
Ein kleines Planspiel, wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel rausfinden wollen würdest, also Informationen über das Land, das heute Deutschland im Fußball einigermaßen abgeledert hat mit 5 zu 1, also Rumänien, wenn du Informationen über Rumänien brauchst, wo guckst du dann zuerst nach? Tatsächlich Google?
Und dann würde ich vielleicht, nach der rumänischen Botschaft oder sowas suchen, keine Ahnung.
Glaubst du wirklich, dass die rumänische Botschaft die Informationen über Rumänien bietet, die dich wirklich interessieren?
Ich weiß ja nicht, was ich über Rumänien jetzt direkt herausfinden will.
Wie es zum Beispiel sein kann, dass ein Land, von dem wir bisher nicht wussten, wo es liegt, uns im Fußball schlägt. Alles klar. Jonathan, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Ja, sonst auf jeden Fall vielleicht noch einen Tipp. Ich finde es immer ganz gut, auch in Foren irgendwie zu gucken und so.
Ist ja sehr mühsam, ne?
Und mal noch eine Frage, weil ja gesagt wurde, mit Google in Anführungsstrichen, also das ist mir schon klar, aber was ich manchmal gerne machen würde, wäre, was in Anführungsstrichen zu setzen und noch andere Wörter. Ist das irgendwie möglich?
Das geht auch.
Ja, du kannst da schon alles kombinieren und mit Plus und Minus da arbeiten.
Vielleicht will ich mal umgucken.
Vielleicht mal Bedienungsanleitung lesen.
Es gibt da auch so eine Hilfe-Seite und dieses Advanced Search, das bietet ja auch ein User-Interface dafür, wie man das sozusagen, welche Worte man drin haben will, welche Worte man nicht drin haben will, ob man nur Ergebnisse einer bestimmten Webseite haben möchte und so weiter.
Und dir auch, tschüss. Falls sonst noch jemand mitreden möchte unter 0331 70 97 1 und 0, könnt ihr das gerne tun. Jetzt mal an die Wikipedia-Experten gefragt. Wenn ich jetzt Informationen, also die Informationen haben möchte, also warum ist Rumänien in der Lage, die Bundesrepublik Deutschland, also quasi das tollste Land der Welt, das unglaublich guten Fußball spielt, 5 zu 1 zu schlagen, würde ich das in der Wikipedia finden?
Zurzeit eher wohl noch nicht. Also tendenziell würde ich sagen, man kann auf jeden Fall ein obskuren Artikel erstmal versuchen anzulegen, in dem das beschrieben ist, aber die Frage ist halt, ob der die Qualitätsstandards erfüllen würde, die unsere Augen, die da ständig auf der Seite letzten Änderungen wachen, darüber wir wahrscheinlich gleich noch ein bisschen mehr reden werden, das dann auch für gut befinden würden und sagen würden, okay, das ist ein Artikel, der Bestandheit und den wir drin lassen.
Also auf jeden Fall... Ich wollte das gleich nochmal ergänzen, weil es gibt ja auf der Wikipedia auch den Link aktuelle Ereignisse. Und dort ist dann das Tagesgeschehen dokumentiert und dort finden wir dann auch Bucharest, Schrägstriche Rumänien. Die deutsche Fußball-Nationalmannschaft verlor ein Testspiel zur Europameisterschaft 2004 in Portugal gegen Rumänien mit 1 zu 5. Torschütze für die Auswahl vom DFB-Teamchef Rudi Völler war Philipp Lahm vom VfB Stuttgart.
Vielleicht ist das einer, der nicht Lahm war.
Ja, vor allem aber auch gleich mit Links auf Bucharest, Rumänien, DFB, Rudi Völler und VfB Stuttgart, sodass man auch sofort zu weiteren Erklärungen kommt. Was halt mehr Information ist, als man jetzt aus einem Spiegel-Online-Artikel darüber machen kann, auch wenn es eine andere Information ist, weil man gleich zu den Metathemen kommt.
Kann ich in der Wikipedia eigentlich auch Töne ablegen?
Klar. Echt?
Also zum Beispiel diesen wunderschönen Dialog zwischen Johannes B. Kerner und Franz Beckenbauer?
Haben Sie schon mal sowas erlebt?
Eigentlich noch nicht, nein. Das Web als Nachschlagewerk im Chaosradio 91. Es gibt natürlich in der Wikipedia dem Nachschlagewerk, das derzeit am stärksten wächst und am interessantesten höchst, der wahrscheinlich auch ist. Eine Seite zu dieser Sendung guckt einfach nach unter chaosradio.ctt.de. Da gibt es einen Link zur Wikipedia, zur Seite zur Sendung und da jede Menge Links auch zu anderen Nachschlagewerken, weil die Wikipedia ja nicht unbedingt das Nachschlagewerk erfunden hat. Gab es zu seiner Zeit schon mal so ein Projekt, das das auch gemacht hat.
h2z2.com Ja, der Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy. Also ich meine, das ist ja im Prinzip die Uridee, zumindest so für die Nerds aus dem Buch Per Anhalter durch die Galaxis. Also das eigentliche Buch, was ja auch so heißt, Per Anhalter durch die Galaxis, was der Encyclopedia Galactica schon längst den Rang abgelaufen hat, weil da nämlich jeder selber Artikel zu beitragen kann, weil es cool ist und weil in großen Lettern draufsteht, keine Panik.
Ja, und weil die Redakteure der Encyclopedia Galactica die ersten waren, ne, die ersten sein werden, die an die Wand gestellt werden, wenn die große Revolution kommt, oder? War das nicht so?
Ne, das war die Sirio-Cybernetics Corporation, die mit den Robotern mit dem echten menschlichen Persönlichkeitsbild.
Steckt da ein Kopel an Schweine.
Aber als Douglas Adams noch gelebt hat, hat er das halt irgendwie vorangetragen. Mittlerweile ist das, ich weiß nicht, ob es von Anfang an schon bei der BBC war, das ist bei der BBC, der Link ist auch auf der Seite zu finden. Und ich hab das nicht so im Detail verfolgt, aber ich glaube, die haben am Anfang noch nicht so ein ganz so ein offenes Modell verfolgt bei der Content-Suche und ich bin mir nicht, also es hat nicht so performt. Die haben auf jeden Fall auch ein Sammelsurium an Informationen. Darüber weiß ich wenig. Es gibt auch noch andere Projekte, insbesondere mit offenem Inhalt, die erwähnenswert sind, wie zum Beispiel das Projekt Gutenberg, was vor allem sich eben auf nicht-lizenzbehaftete, schon existierende Texte gestürzt hat, die eben ein großes Sammelsurium an den Urtexten der Menschheitsgeschichte irgendwie versucht hat zusammenzutragen und auch immer noch tut. Es gibt auch verschiedene Varianten, hast du gesagt?
Es gibt halt die Englische, die ist wirklich frei. Also da kann man einfach die Texte nehmen und kann sie auch weiter bearbeiten und so weiter, wie man das halt gerade für sinnvoll achtet. Es gibt auch eine deutsche Variante, die sind da ein bisschen restriktiver. Also die glauben dadurch, dass sie die Texte nochmal neu eingegeben haben, bzw. eingescannt oder wie auch immer, dass sie daran gleichzeitig sozusagen wieder neue Rechte erworben haben und versuchen, da so ein bisschen den Daumen drauf zu halten.
Moment mal, die nehmen rechte, freie Texte, schreiben die in HTML rein und sagen dann, das gehört jetzt uns?
So hab ich's verstanden, ja. Also das ist ein bisschen irritierend.
Steckt da irgendwie Bill Gates hinter?
Der steht jetzt vor allem Spiegel Online dahinter, die das ja hosten und auch so in ihrem Spiegel Online-Look präsentieren. Ob man das nun mögen soll, ich weiß nicht. So richtig toll. Also Projekt Gutenberg hatte am Anfang eigentlich immer sehr gute Credits. Mir ist es nicht so häufig jetzt unter die Nase gekommen. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall eine interessante Ressource, um eben solche Texte nachzuschlagen. Aber auch da gibt es im Wikipedia-Universum bereits entsprechende Projekte, die auch daran arbeiten, eben alte Quellen, die lizenzfrei sind, zu sammeln. Ein ähnlich erfolgreiches und gut frequentiertes Projekt ist everything2.com, was auch so ähnlich arbeitet technisch wie die Wikipedia. Man kann da irgendwie beliebig reinschreiben und man macht halt so explizite Links auf andere Seiten. Da gibt es auch ein großes Sammelsurium, auch sehr interessante Informationen zu Tagesgeschehen. Man linkt da halt explizit auch immer auf Tage. Also es ist eine schöne Chronologie der Welt, die sich dort auch findet.
Das heißt, da könnte ich Rumänien finden.
Da gibt es sicherlich auch einiges zum Thema Rumänien.
Aber was natürlich der Unterschied ist, dass man da nicht jetzt die Sachen, die andere schon geschrieben haben, nochmal überarbeiten kann und zusammenfassen kann oder Fehler korrigieren, sondern dass da schon das eher so ist, dass immer auf einer Seite jeder, ähnlich wie bei einem Forum oder sowas, jetzt seine Passage, seine Erklärung zu einer bestimmten Sache drunter setzt und nochmal drunter setzt und das dadurch halt mehr so ein Sammelsurums Charakter hat, was auch eine eigene Reiz hat auf jeden Fall, gerade wenn es so um kulturelle Geschichten geht, also wenn man ein Sprichwort nachschlagen möchte auf Englisch, weil man es nicht genau verstanden hat oder sowas. Aber ja, die Qualität ist doch sehr unterschiedlich und ja, manchmal findet man noch einfach nur Müll. Was in der Wikipedia natürlich auch manchmal auch nicht anders ist, muss man sagen.
Ja gut, also ich meine, in der Wikipedia, ich kann da ja schreiben. Da darf ja Hintz und Kunst, Kreti und Pleti dürfen schreiben. Anonym wie Pseudonym wie auch immer. Was passiert, wenn ich da Stuss reinschreibe?
Dann kannst du davon ausgehen, dass es selten länger als fünf Minuten überleben wird. Also kann durchaus sein, dass es innerhalb von wenigen Sekunden schon wieder ganz gelöscht ist, weil wenn es totaler Nonsens war, bzw. wenn es auf der Kippe steht, dass manche Leute sagen, man könnte es rauslöschen, weil es nicht sehr ergiebig ist, und andere sagen, naja, ein guter Ansatz ist vielleicht da, eine Begriffserklärung, und dann kommt es auf die Löschkandidaten. Das ist also eine Seite, auf der alle Sachen gelistet werden, von denen Leute glauben, dass es besser nicht bei uns reinpassen würde. Und dann findet eine Diskussion statt. Dann hat der Artikel sozusagen eine Gnadenfrist von sieben Tagen. Und dann wird abgestimmt diskutiert und überlegt und verbessert. Und dann im Ende der sieben Tage wird dann entschieden.
Kommunales Gehabe.
Ja, aber es funktioniert super.
Ja Also die Wikipedia, eine Enzyklopädie online, in der jeder mitschreiben darf, auf das sie wachse und zwar möglichst schnell und möglichst groß. Wer ist wann drauf gekommen oder war das eine Zwangsläufigkeit, dass sich das Ding gebildet hat?
Nee, eine Zwangsläufigkeit würde ich nicht sagen. Also die Idee von Wikis an sich, also von einer Seitensammlung im Internet, die man live bearbeiten kann, wo jeder hin surfen kann, auf bearbeiten, klicken, Text verändern, wie abspeichern, die gibt es schon ein bisschen länger, da sind 95 die ersten entstanden. Dann gab es Nupedia, das ist ein Projekt gewesen, wo man auf mehrkömmlichen Wegen versucht hat, eine Enzyklopädie zu erstellen, also schön mit Wissenschaftlern, die dann gegenseitig ihre Artikel korrekturgelesen haben, noch mal korrekturgelesen haben, noch mal korrekturgelesen haben, und wo irgendwann keiner mehr so richtig Lust hatte, weiterzumachen, weil das ganze Ding halt sozusagen an der Struktur erstickt ist, weil das ist dann irgendwann gegen die Wand gefahren so ein bisschen. Und man hat gemerkt, okay, irgendwie müssen wir ein bisschen mehr Leben reinbringen, und dann fiel jemand ein, ach ja, da gibt's ja diese Wikis, setz doch einfach mal eins auf, gucken wir mal, schreiben wir da einen Artikel rein und gucken, was passiert. Und dann ist das Ding halt sehr schnell abgegangen, wie eine Rakete. Dann plötzlich war Wikipedia, also das war halt dieses Wiki, was aufgesetzt worden ist, das Ding, wo die Experten hingewandert sind und mitgeschrieben haben, und ja, Nupedia war tot, Wikipedia war geboren. Und ja, seitdem wächst es und wächst es und wächst es und wächst es.
Wie viele haben wir mittlerweile, wie viele Beiträge?
Gute Frage. 380.000, 84.000, vielleicht sind wir schon bei 85.000.
Deutsche jetzt weltweit, wie viele sind das?
Die Deutsche stößt jetzt gerade an 84.000 an und die Englische hat gerade die 250.000 durchschritten.
Und insgesamt sind wir bei 600.000, vielleicht auch schon bei 700.000.
In wie vielen Sprachen?
In über 70 Sprachen zurzeit.
70 Sprachen, das schließt übrigens auch so was wie Plattdeutsch mit ein.
Auch Rumänisch?
Sicherlich und auch Esperanto.
Ja, ein paar Kunstsprachen.
Da war ich ja noch nie.
In Esperantoland? Ja, da kommst du auch noch mal irgendwann hin.
Ich tue sie ja auch.
Wenn Fritz in Eisenhüttenstatt, dann 100, 1.
22.30 Fritz Info. Mit dem Wetter heute Nacht ist es nur gering bewölkt. Die Temperaturen sinken auf 9 bis 5 Grad. Morgen dann heiter bis wolkig. Maximal Temperaturen um die 23 Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Matthias Kerkhoff.
Die US-Luftwaffe hat am Abend der Neustellungen von Aufständischen in der irakischen Stadt Fallujah angegriffen. Augenzeugen berichteten, dass Munitionslager getroffen und explodiert seien. US-Präsident Bush hatte bereits weitere Militäraktionen angekündigt. In Berlin haben Vertreter aus 55 Ländern über einen Aktionsplan gegen den Antisemitismus beraten. Außenminister Fischer forderte dabei die Staaten auf, sich gemeinsam mit allen Formen des Antisemitismus auseinanderzusetzen. Die Konferenz wird morgen fortgesetzt. Das Auswärtige Amt hat vor Reisen in den Süden Thailands gewarnt. Dort sind bei den bislang schwersten Unruhen mehr als 100 aufständische Moslems von der Polizei getötet worden. Die muslimische Minderheit in Thailand fühlt sich von der Regierung diskriminiert. Zum Sport. Die deutsche Fußballnationalmannschaft hat das Länderspiel gegen Rumänien verloren. Mit einem deutlichen 1 zu 5 Unterlagen sehen Bukarest Oliver Kahn nach dem Spiel.
Für dieses Spiel gibt es überhaupt keine Entschuldigung. Es ist auch egal, ob die Mannschaft so noch nie zusammengespielt hat. Es spielt auch keine Rolle, dass viele Spieler kurz vorm Spiel noch ausgefallen sind, verletzt. Man muss vorsichtig sein mit solchen Aussagen, aber das war schon eine absolute Blamage und ein sehr, sehr großer Rückschlag.
Erfolgreicher waren dagegen die deutschen Fußballfrauen. Sie haben bei der EM-Qualifikation gegen die Ukraine mit 6 zu 0 gewonnen und bei der Eishockey WM bezwang der Gastgeber Tschechien Deutschland soeben mit 5 zu 1. Der Verkehr Fritz mit einer Meldung von der A100, das ist der Stadtring Berlin. Berlin Wedding Richtung Berlin Wilmersdorf zwischen Beusselstraße und Jakob Kaiserplatz gab es eine Unfall-Sperrung. Der linke Fahrstreifen ist gesperrt, meldet die Polizei. Ansonsten wünschen wir eine gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank, Matthias. Hast du eben 5 zu 1 schon wieder gesagt?
Irgendwas ist heute nicht in Ordnung.
Und jetzt die Veranstaltungshinweise. Am 2. Mai musiziert in der Columbia-Halle das Braunschweiger Unterhaltungsensemble ich buchstabiere OOMPH.
Wusstet ihr eigentlich, dass das rumänische Bruttoinland-Produkt von 2002 im Vergleich zu 2001 trotz schwieriger Weltwirtschaftslage um 4, 9% gewachsen ist?
Wo hast du das denn her?
Aus der Wikipedia. Was steht denn da eigentlich über Tschechien? Die haben uns doch auch 5 zu 1 abgeledert, zwar jetzt nicht im Fußball, sondern im Dingens.
Im Dingens?
Ja hier, wie heißt das?
Korbball.
Ice Hockey.
Fingert es nicht aneinander.
Ich bin ein wenig müde. Chaosradio 91, es geht um Nachschlagwege im Web.
Wir haben auf jeden Fall schon Feedback hier auf der Feedback-Seite in der Wikipedia. Da sind wir auch gerade auf ein anderes interessantes Projekt hingewiesen worden, nämlich die PeriPedia.
Vielleicht sollte man dazu sagen, dass es auch eine Chaosradio-Seite zur heutigen Sendung in der Wikipedia gibt.
Ja das hatten wir schon erwähnt, also der Link kann ich auch gerne nochmal erwähnen, also auf unserer Chaosradio-Homepage, also chaosradio.de, dort findet ihr den Link dorthin, weil den sag ich jetzt mal nicht so durch. Steht allerdings auf der Homepage von der Wikipedia, ist es auch verlinkt, also ihr findet das und dann gibt es dort auch nochmal einen Link auf die Feedback-Seite, wo ihr einfach so Feedback eintragen könnt, das lesen wir hier live. Und gut, da kam eben, Martin meinte, dass er an der Peripedia mitarbeitet, das kannte ich noch nicht, und das ist auf der gleichen Software der Wikipedia, ein Perironenlexikon. Was natürlich ganz interessant ist, weil in der Wikipedia wird so Fan-Tum nicht so gerne gesehen. Also es ist natürlich so eine Sache, dass Begriffe, die man so gut kennt wie Donald Duck oder Intenhausen, die finden sich da irgendwie schon, aber das sind dann schon so etwas, die eher umstrittenen Beiträge, da es sich ja dabei nicht um wirkliches Weltwissen handelt, sondern eben so sekundäres Kulturprodukt. Und sicherlich gibt es darüber eine Menge interessante Dinge zu erzählen, aber man muss halt natürlich schon so ein bisschen Realität und Fiktion auseinanderhalten. Und deswegen gibt es auch diverse Spin-offs, wie zum Beispiel diese Peripedia. Ein anderes Beispiel ist die Wikipedia-artige Seite der Trekkies. Irgendwo hab ich es hingeschrieben, aber finde ich jetzt gerade nicht.
Starfleet Academy irgendwie so ähnlich, ne?
Während du suchst, könnte ich ja unsere Zuhörer... memoryalpha.org dort ist halt die Trekkies-Szene und trägt sich da zusammen. Sie arbeiten da natürlich auch enzyklopädisch, aber eben in ihrer eigenen Welt. Also natürlich Perironen und Star Trek Universum auf jeden Fall gute Beispiele. Wird sicherlich nicht mehr lange dauern, bis die Donaldisten auch ihre Entenhausen-Enzyklopädie zusammentragen, weil das wäre auf jeden Fall konfliktfreier als in der Wikipedia, wo es natürlich dann immer so um die Enzyklopädiehaftigkeit der Artikel dann auch sehr viel Auseinandersetzung gibt, zurecht.
Jetzt ist die Wikipedia ja was, was non-profit ist. Und du sagtest eben Donald Duck da rein zu tun, also ich hab mal geguckt, Donald Duck, da wird ein Donald Duck Foto abgebildet, gibt's keinen Ärger? Also ich mein, weil jeder, der Rechte an Donald Duck hat, möchte doch damit Geld verdienen und einfach mal ein Foto im Web auf einer eigenen Seite veröffentlichen, das darf man doch nicht.
Das ist richtig, also Lizenz, also der Inhalt der Wikipedia ist wird unter der GNU freien Dokumentationslizenz veröffentlicht. Kurt, kannst du mal da mal was zu sagen?
Die GNU Lizenz für freie Dokumentation. Also das ist eine Lizenz, die eigentlich entstanden ist, so in der Freie Software, Open Source Bewegung. Also weil da natürlich die Leute ihre Programme geprogrammiert haben, die ganzen GNU Tools, Linux und so weiter, und sich gesagt haben, man, die ganzen Programme sind frei, also das heißt, jeder kann die Programme, den Quelltext der Programme nehmen, kopieren, bearbeiten, neue Programme damit schreiben. Und irgendwie hat man das gleiche Prinzip auch gerne verwirklicht bei den Texten, bei den Anleitungstexten. Und dann hat man sich also hingesetzt und sich also eine Lizenz überlegt, die nun für Texte ein bisschen passender ist als so eine Lizenz für Quelltexte. Und ja, dabei ist halt die GNU Lizenz für freie Dokumentation rausgekommen. Und das ist die Lizenz, die wir auch verwenden. Also die gewährleistet, dass jeder die Wikipedia nehmen kann, einzelne Artikel nehmen kann, die ganze Datenbank nehmen kann, kopieren, weiterverarbeiten. Auch die Software, die wir benutzen, kann man sich installieren und runterladen. Und dann kann man die ganzen Datenbank einspielen und cut sozusagen eine 1 zu 1 Kopie von dem, was wir auch auf unseren Servern liegen haben.
Inklusive des Fotos von Donald?
Ähm, Fotos zurzeit... Fotos von Donald Duck gibt es bisher noch nicht. Der ist noch nicht gesichtet worden. Also im Gegensatz zum Yeti, gibt es glaube ich niemanden, der wirklich behauptet ihm schon mal begegnet zu sein.
Also es ist zumindest ein Foto einer Donald Duck Figur.
Es ist ein 3D Rendering, wenn ich mich recht erinnere.
Ein 3D Rendering.
Wenn du mal auf das Bild selber draufklickst, dann findest du dann auch entsprechende Informationen zu dem Bild selber, also mit den Bildern. Die Bilder werden im Prinzip auch als eigene.
Fotografie einer dreidimensionalen Figur, das ist durch die Hintertür sozusagen.
Genau, durch die Hintertür sozusagen nachgemodelt, aber es ist auch sozusagen ein eigenes Werk, was durch eigenes Rendering entstanden ist. Das ist dann eben auch der entscheidende Punkt. Das ist natürlich gerade jetzt bei der Abbildung von Persönlichkeiten schwierige Sache, weniger bei Personen der Zeitgeschichte beziehungsweise so jemand wie Johann Sebastian Bach irgendwie. Da wird sich halt kaum jemand melden, der sagt, das ist aber mein Foto. Aber bei Prominenten des aktuellen Geschehens ist das sehr wohl ein Problem, weil da kommt dann der Fotograf mit rein, dann hat das Recht auf das eigene Bild natürlich dann auch nochmal eine Holze spielen. Und dieser ganze Lizenzkram ist natürlich auch ein großes Problem für solche Projekte. Und das ist ja im Prinzip genau auch der Versuch, davon wegzukommen, dass man eben sagt, alles was jetzt hier ist und was selbst erarbeitet ist, wo die Leute sagen, das gebe ich jetzt hier in die Öffentlichkeit und ich stelle es jedermann zur freien Verfügung bereit, dass man eben ab dem Zeitpunkt, wo das geklärt ist, eben zumindest das nehmen kann. Dass man eben damit arbeiten kann, dass man mit den Texten arbeiten kann, dass man mit den Bildern, mit den Fotos arbeiten kann, ohne dass man eben diesen ganzen Lizenzstress hat, mit dem sich die Welt heute so belegt.
Also ein Wort, das dafür ganz gern oft genommen wird, ist die Wissensalmende. Almende des Wissens. Almende war früher in einem Dorf die Wiese, die alle benutzen durften. Also wo alle ihr Vieh raufjagen durften, bis er weiden konnte. Und ja, sozusagen ein Gemeinschaftseigentum. Und das Gleiche im übertragenen Sinne versuchen wir auch zu schaffen. Also wir versuchen, ein Bestandteil an Texten, Bildern, vielleicht auch Videos zunächst mal zu schaffen, die jeder benutzen kann, die jeder kopieren kann und für eigene Zwecke einsetzen darf.
Scheitert vielleicht das Wachstum der Wikipedia vielleicht irgendwann daran, dass die Leute gerne Grafiken und bunt und schön haben wollen und weniger lesen.
Dafür meinst du, dass das Wachstum in Kilobyte oder wie?
Wie auch immer. Also die Menge einer Tiegel.
Na ja, ich meine, du weißt ja, was auf eine Festplatte heute so raufpasst und was das so kostet. Also das ist eigentlich...
Na gut, ich weiß nicht, ob der normale Clickybunti-User dann bereit ist, tatsächlich lange Texte zu lesen, ob er es nicht vielleicht dann lieber in bunt haben will.
Na ja, also man muss halt gucken. Also an sich sind wir natürlich grafisch nicht abgeneigt. Also zurzeit, würde ich sagen, sind viele Texte noch eher eine Bleiwüste, wo ab und zu mal eine Grafik oder ein Foto gar nicht schaden kann. Also noch, würde ich sagen, lieber im Zweifelsfall rein. Also würde ich eher andersrum denken.
Ist das eine grundsätzliche Philosophie, lieber im Zweifelsfall rein? Also alles rein?
Sei mutig! Sei mutig ist der Ansatz und das Motto der Wikipedia. Deswegen haben wir das auch in den Titel dieser Sendung gestellt. In dem Moment, wo man sich eben überlegt, passt das oder passt das nicht. Also bei Lizenzfragen ist nochmal eine andere Sache. Aber wenn man der Meinung ist, passt das oder passt das nicht, dann gilt die Devise, sei mutig, tu es erst mal. Wenn es falsch ist, dann wird sicherlich eine Diskussion aufbrausen. Wenn du totale Scheiße geschrieben hast, dann ist es in der Garantie in 10 Minuten entfernt. Aber grundsätzlich soll man erst mal proaktiv voranschreiten und es einfach tun.
Genau, man muss versuchen, wegzukommen von diesem Autorendenken. So, das hab ich geschrieben, das andere haben andere geschrieben. Was die anderen geschrieben haben, das fahre ich nicht an. Ich mach nur das, was ich selber geschrieben habe oder so. Sondern dass man sozusagen wirklich so einen Gemeinschaftsdenken entwickelt und sagt, okay, wenn der irgendwo einen Komma vergessen hat, wenn der irgendwo einen Satz vergessen hat oder Fakten ausgelassen hat oder vielleicht einen Standpunkt fehlt zu einer bestimmten eine bestimmte Sichtweise auf einem bestimmten Gegenstand, dann ergänze ich den einfach. Ich persönlich freue mich immer, wenn meine Artikel ergänzt werden, von anderen Leuten, Korrektur gelesen werden. Es ist einfach ein tolles Gefühl, dabei zuzugucken.
Der Macht hat Recht.
Das ist Anarchie. Es gibt zum Beispiel auch eine Seite zu Fritz, Klammer auf Radio, Klammer zu. Also wenn du nur Fritz eingibst, dann bekommst du erst mal auf eine sogenannte Begriffsklärungsseite. Weil es gibt natürlich verschiedene Dinge, die man mit Fritz bezeichnen kann. Da ist das Radio nur eins davon. Die gängige Schreibweise in der Wikipedia ist dann eben einen klärenden Metabegriff in Klammern dahinter zu setzen, damit man weiß, in welcher Domäne sich das bewegt. Also ist das ein Begriff aus der Biologie, ist das ein Begriff aus der Informatik oder aus der Philosophie oder was genau beschreibt es denn eigentlich? In dem Sinne ist Fritz, Klammer auf Radio, die korrekte Bezeichnung. Find ich überhaupt auch schon mal bemerkenswert, dass da nicht Radio Fritz drin steht, sondern das schon zur Kenntnis genommen wurde, dass dieser Sender sich ja eben Fritz nennt und nicht Radio Fritz.
Ich will jetzt nichts Falsches behaupten, aber ich glaube sogar, dass ich ursprünglich mal diesen Satz, Fritz ist ein in Brandenburg und Berlin verbreiteter Jugendsender oder sowas geschrieben habe. Und da hab ich glaube ich noch Radio Fritz geschrieben damals.
Du meinst Indie Wikipedia? Na dann klick doch mal auf Versionen, dann wirst du das... Ich bin dir nicht sicher. Du bist nicht angemeldet gewesen wahrscheinlich, ne?
Damals nein.
Dann müsstest du deine IP-Adresse von damals noch erinnern. Das schaffst du nicht, der Geek.
Elessa ist hier eingetragen als der erste Autor. Elessa.
Das ist halt auch eine schöne Eigenschaft.
Ich weiß nur, dass ich einmal wirklich selbst was in die Wikipedia geschrieben hab. Ich glaube, es hatte mit Fritz zu tun.
Na ja, da sind auch ein paar IP-Adressen hier.
Also das ist eine sehr schöne Eigenschaft, dass man eben nicht nur fertige Artikel bekommt, oder unfertige Artikel bekommt, sondern dass man eben über jeden Artikel sich die vollständige Versionshistorie anzeigen lassen kann. Das heißt, man sieht ganz genau, wann, wer, sofern dieser wer bereit war, das auch zu dokumentieren, wer er war, also einen eigenen Benutzer-Account hat in der Wikipedia. Sonst steht da nur eine IP-Adresse. Und welche Änderungen er auch konkret vorgenommen hat. Das heißt, man bekommt dann so eine Differenzanzeige, was wurde herausgenommen, was wurde neu eingefügt, schön mit Gelb und Grün farblich hinterlegt und dann nochmal mit Rot explizit die Zeichen markiert, die sich eben konkret geändert haben, also die hinzugekommen sind. Und so kann man eben auch bestimmten anderen Problemen, wie Vandalismus, dass jemand einfach sagt, was ist denn das für ein Scheiß, weg damit, ich lösche das jetzt mal alles, ganz gut begegnen kann. Das sieht man eben sofort. Man kann einfach auf eine alte Version zurückgreifen und die wieder herstellen. Und so hat eigentlich Vandalismus auch wenig Chancen.
Chaosradio 91, das Web als Nachschlagewerk.
Ja, wir versuchen hier einen neutralen Standpunkt einzunehmen. Das ist ein wichtiger Punkt bei der Wikipedia. Man wird dazu angehalten, beim Schreiben von Artikeln und natürlich auch beim Ergänzenden und Korrigieren von Artikeln, möglichst den betrachteten Begriff möglichst neutral zu beschreiben. Das ist natürlich jetzt ein dehnbarer Begriff und der wird auch immer sehr gedehnt, aber es ist klar, dass man da eben jetzt nicht wie ein Fan einfach draus losschreibt mit irgendwie Boris Becker ist der größte oder ohne Holger Klein kann ich nicht leben. Das wird dann halt natürlich sofort korrigiert.
Da würde ich außer mir sowieso keinen kennen.
Ja, und was der Clou ja bei dem neutralen Standpunkt ist, dass man also nicht versucht, einen objektiven Standpunkt einzunehmen, also objektiv in dem Sinne, dass man sozusagen die eine richtige Wahrheit findet, wie das vielleicht in manchen anderen Enzyklopädi in der Fall ist, sondern ein neutraler Standpunkt meint, man versucht alle relevanten Standpunkte durchzugehen in einem Artikel. Ja, also sowohl die Pro- als auch die Kontra-Meinungen gelten.
Entschuldige, das ist doch utopisch zu glauben, dass das geht.
Wieso soll das nicht gehen?
Alle möglichen Standpunkte.
Na, alle relevanten Standpunkte.
Ja, aber da bist du doch schon nicht mehr neutral, indem du sagst, dieser Standpunkt ist relevant und dieser ist nicht relevant. Also wenn du wirklich neutral sein willst, dann kannst du dich nur in Fakten halten.
Du kannst ja zum Beispiel gucken, was gibt es für wissenschaftliche Publikationen zu einem bestimmten Thema. Wie sehen die meisten Wissenschaftler das? Was wird häufig zu einem bestimmten Thema geschrieben? Was sind eher Randgruppenmeinungen?
Ja, aber dann müsste in der Wikipedia stehen, dass Gott existiert.
Warum müsste das da stehen?
Weil das die verbreitetste Meinung ist.
Nee, weil in der Wikipedia müsste stehen, Leute, die an Religionen glauben, glauben auch teilweise auch an Gott. Und es gibt Leute, die das nicht glauben und die glauben nicht an Gott. Ja, also dass du das so auf aufteuern kannst, sagen kannst, die und die Gruppen sind der und der Meinung und die und die anderen Gruppen sind der und der Meinung.
Vielleicht ist Gott auch ein sehr schlechtes Beispiel.
Ja, Gott ist auf jeden Fall so ein Beitrag, wo es dann schnell mal zu einem sogenannten Edit War kommen kann. Also als Edit War bezeichnet man eben das, ja, gehäufte Abändern eines Artikels, meist wechselseitig von Vertretern unterschiedlicher Standpunkte. Es gibt ja natürlich eine ganze Menge Themen, wo man eben nicht zwangsläufig einer Meinung ist, auch wenn man die gleiche Sprache spricht. Und wenn es auffällt, und es fällt in der Regel schnell auf, dass eben so ein Artikel unter Beschuss ist, weil der eine sieht es halt so, der andere sieht es halt so. Dir werden sicherlich noch ein paar gute Beispiele einfallen gefällt, ich könnte jetzt zum Beispiel bei Gott in der Wikipedia einfach mal reinschreiben, Gott ist doof. Du könntest das mal jetzt reinschreiben und ich könnte garantieren, dass diese Sendung auf gar keinen Fall überlebt.
Und da zieht sich halt sofort der demokratischen Kontrolle durch all die anderen Nutzer und du wirst natürlich relativ schnell jemanden finden. Es sei denn, der sich damit nicht einpasst, es sei denn alle anderen sind der Meinung Gott gesperrt.
Wir erzählen derweil nochmal was.
Wobei so was natürlich eher unter Vandalismus fällt. Also einfach stupide Sachen da reinzuschreiben. Und da würden wir dann eher so gegen vorgehen, dass wir einfach dann den Nutzer sperren. Also wir können halt gucken, welche IP-Adresse das verfasst. Und wenn jetzt jemand da rumnervt, dann kann man den einfach mal für eine Stunde oder für zwei oder wenn der ganz da rumnervt, auch für einen Tag von die Tür setzen und sagen, der muss sich das vielleicht ein bisschen wieder abkühlen und kann dann wieder vorbeigucken.
Wenn ich auf Seite bearbeiten klicke, dann steht da dumm die dumm als einziger Text, den ich bearbeiten kann.
Dann hat gerade jemand die Endschritte vorgebracht.
Wir sind ja jetzt dabei, hier auch die Leute zu wilden Taten zu überreden. Aber du kannst jetzt mal, du hast ja keinen Account, du kannst jetzt Gott auf deine Beobachtungsliste setzen und dann würdest du auch schnell mitbekommen, dass sich da was getan hat.
Es hat sich schon was getan. Mittlerweile steht überhaupt nichts mehr da. Also da stand sehr viel über Glaubenskonzept und so. Mittlerweile steht da nur noch God is great.
Ich sehe das hier übrigens gerade. Es gibt übrigens einen IRC-Kanal auf IRC-Freenote-Net. Unter lattensound.de, irc.wikipedia sieht man alle Änderungen. Da sehe ich hier gerade, also Gott wurde von IP-Adresse 217, 231, 82 geändert. Kurze Zeit später von IP-Adresse 80, 129, 253.9. Wir kennen eure Namen, ihr habt keine Chance. Jetzt gibt es schon die nächste Änderung. Diesmal von Paddy und... Oh Gott, jetzt haben wir der Wikipedia hier. Das wollten wir natürlich nicht. Aber es wird sich selbst heilen. Das funktioniert halt wunderbar. Weil es gibt hier eine definierte Machtstruktur unter Wikipedia Doppelpunkt Machtstruktur auch detailliert aufgeführt mit unterschiedlichen Rollen. Also da gibt es halt erstmal so die Unknown Users. Das sind halt die Leute, die sich nicht dort registrieren und die einfach nur als IP-Adresse dort auftauchen. Dann gibt es eben die registrierten Benutzer. Die dürfen auch alles ändern. Die dürfen auch Artikel umbenennen, also verschieben. Redirects, Umleitungen von dem einen Begriff auf den anderen einrichten.
Das hat sich gerade geheilt, ja.
Sie dürfen keine Artikel löschen. Dera gibt es glaube ich derzeit so 30.
In der Deutschen sind es doch ein bisschen mehr, oder?
Ich hab noch nicht mal geschaut, aber es ist 30.
Ich hatte jetzt schon noch so 50 getippt oder so, aber ich bin ja auch nicht so ganz sicher. Auf jeden Fall, ja, Administratoren sind Leute, denen wir vertrauen. Also, wo wir sicher sind, die haben... Wir großgeschrieben, ja. Nein, das sind Leute, wo man sagen kann, die sind schon eine Zeit lang beim Projekt dabei, die haben bisher gute Arbeit geleistet, die stehen nicht im Verdacht, dass sie irgendwelchen Nonsens machen, sondern die helfen gerne anderen neuen Nutzer noch aus. Und dann kriegen die Admin-Rechte, das heißt, die haben dann solche Möglichkeiten, dass sie einen Artikel löschen dürfen, sie dürfen Benutzer sperren.
Schusch weist gerade im Chat drauf hin, dass es 60 Admins sind.
Zwischenfrage. Ich bin nicht mehr in der Lage, die Seite zu ändern.
Dann ist die Seite jetzt gerade vor dem Administrator gesperrt worden.
Da ist ein Administrator gerade zur Tat geschrieben.
Also ich bin jetzt nur noch in der Lage, den Quelltext zu betrachten.
Wir haben jetzt alles total verrückt gemacht und jeder möchte das gerne mal ausprobieren. Dann haben die gesehen, okay, jetzt haben wir hier einen totalen Edit-War. Das wollen wir jetzt verhindern, dann wird die Seite jetzt erstmal gesperrt. Jetzt wird erstmal, solange die Sendung läuft über Gott, wird jetzt erstmal nicht diskutiert.
Wer diskutiert, kann diskutieren auf der Diskussionseite.
AUS! 23 Uhr, Chaos Radio 91. Das Web als Nachschlagewerk, insbesondere natürlich die Wikipedia zu erreichen, unter wikipedia.de ist das Thema im heutigen Chaosradio. Ich hab eben versucht unter Gott, Gott ist doof zu schreiben. Wenn ich mir jetzt Gott ist doof hätte vorher schützen lassen und hätte das da reingeschrieben, hätte ich euch dann verklagen können eigentlich.
Meinst du als Slogan oder was?
Ja, zum Beispiel, also.
Du meinst, man nicht liebe, es da reinschreiben würde, ja?
Nein, also ganz viele Begriffe sind ja markengerechtlich geschützt und natürlich.
Stimmt, was passiert, wenn ich Tempo schreibe?
Da passiert gar nichts. Natürlich können wir einen Artikel über Tempo schreiben. Warum sollten wir das nicht machen dürfen? Haben wir nicht schon einen? Nein, also das ist ein Problem. Also was eher ein Problem ist, wenn Leute jetzt zum Beispiel ganze Passagen aus fremden Texten nehmen. Also irgendwie bei Google jetzt, sie wollen einen neuen Artikel schreiben, geben bei Google das ein, nehmen den ersten Treffer, kopieren den Text zu uns rüber und denken, sie haben eine gute Tat getan. Das haben sie natürlich nicht, weil sie machen uns damit einfach nur ganz viel Arbeit. Weil wir das natürlich bemerken, dass die Sachen von woanders kopiert sind. Dann müssen wir erst mal recherchieren, so war das jetzt der richtige Autor, der das bei uns reingestellt hat? Oder hat das einfach nur irgendjemand reingestellt? Dann muss es gelöscht werden. Und deswegen, also bitte Leute, wenn ihr uns was Gutes tun wollt, schreibt die Artikel selber. Recherchiert selber, ihr könnt gerne Quellen ohne Ende ranziehen, könnt Sachen paraphrasieren, also mit eigenen Worten nochmal neu erzählen und so. Aber nicht einfach eins zu eins von fremden Webseiten was nehmen, weil das hilft uns überhaupt gar nicht.
Kann ich was schreiben mit einer Quellenangabe und darum bitten, dass ihr darum fragt, ob ihr das benutzen darf dürft? Also irgendwas rein...
Frag doch selber, sei mutig und frag selber.
Anarchiescheiße.
Na ja, in dem Machtstrukturdokument der Wikipedia werden verschiedene Gesellschaftsmodelle herangezogen, um die Gesamtmachtgefüge zu bezeichnen als Anarchie. Nur das erste davon, das sind die mit den IP-Adressen. Außerdem gibt es dort noch Diktatur, Demokratie, Republik, Meritokratie, Plutokratie und die Technokratie, die alle, irgendeine von, entschuldigen.
Was ist eine Meritokratie?
Da schlagst du doch nahe.
Ach so, Entschuldigung, ja.
Meritokratie ist, wenn die Leute sich Anerkennung in der Gemeinschaft erwerben, in dem sie was geleistet haben.
Meriten verdienen.
Und das ist bei uns auch so. Wie gesagt, Administrator wird man dann, wenn man schon ein bisschen was geleistet hat und gezeigt hat, dass man produktiv mitarbeitet.
Das heißt, auf die Auto-OP-Liste komme ich nicht so einfach.
Nee, nicht so einfach.
Na gut, dann gehe ich lieber weiter bei wissen.de. Das hat auch schöne Pop-ups.
Du kannst da ja durchaus auch mit reinkommen. Ich meine, man muss sich dem überhaupt erst mal nähern. Nachdem wir jetzt so schön gezeigt haben, wie man eben nicht mit der Wikipedia arbeiten sollte, also einfach irgendwas reinhauen und ändern und so. Es hält nicht lange. Man hat gesehen, das System reagiert sehr schnell. Das System sind einfach die Leute dahinter. Aber wenn man sich dem erst mal nähern möchte, wie denn das eigentlich so zu sein hat und was der richtige Weg ist, muss man es halt erst mal verstehen. Und wenn man es verstehen will, muss man es erst mal anschauen. Und dann sollte man eben erst mal lesen. Es gibt einen schönen Link auf der Wikipedia, zufälliger Artikel, links oben im Menü. Das benutze ich auch gerne. Da klickt man ruf und dann kommt halt genau das, was eben irgendein Artikel aus den 84.000, die da halt jetzt drin sind. Und den kann man sich dann durchlesen. Man findet vielleicht einen Rechtschreibfehler oder ein Komma ist nicht an der richtigen Stelle. Oder man weiß vielleicht sogar etwas darüber und ergänzt das dann in dem Moment. So kann man dann eben so schrittweise erst mal über das Bearbeiten eines anderen Artikels sich überhaupt an das Schreiben in der Wikipedia gewöhnen. Man kann dann auch den Artikel, den man verändert hat, auf seiner eigenen Beobachtungsliste sehen und dann schauen über die nächsten Tage, ob es auf die eigene Änderung eine Reaktion gibt von anderen Leuten, die das vielleicht rückgängig machen oder geradezu als Aufforderungen empfinden, weil man vielleicht schon einen wichtigen Aspekt hinzugefügt hat, der so noch nicht erwähnt worden war, aber den nicht so richtig zu Ende geführt hat. Und dann kommt jemand anderes, meint es, ah ja, ist ja im Prinzip eine tolle Idee, aber das sollte man vielleicht nochmal ergänzen um und den Bezug auf und macht noch einen Link auf einen anderen Artikel in der Wikipedia. Also wächst das halt eben ganz automatisch. Also man kann mit jeder kleineren Änderung schon auch was anstoßen. Man muss nicht unbedingt immer alles selber machen.
Genau, was natürlich auch ein Vorteil ist, ist wenn man sich anmeldet bei uns. Also dann wird das alles ein bisschen übersichtlicher. Man hat, wie gesagt, dieses Beobachtungs, diese Beobachtungslistenfunktion. Man hat eine Benutzerseite, man hat eine Benutzerdiskussionsseite. Das heißt, Leute können dann mit einem in Kontakt treten und können sagen hier, ich habe die und die Sache, hast du vielleicht da nicht so ganz richtig ausgedrückt, wie siehst du das? Oder können Nachfragen stellen. Man kann auf der Benutzerseite ein bisschen was über sich selber schreiben, vielleicht sein Homepage verlinken und ein Bild über sich reinstellen.
Ich bin jetzt immer noch nicht in der Lage, den Text zu Gott zu verändern. Ist jetzt niemand in der Lage, den Text dazu zu verändern, weil es einfach zu sehr... Nur Admins können das jetzt noch machen. Bin ich jetzt für die gesamte Wikipedia gesperrt damit? Also ist meine IP-Adresse...
Nein, die Seite ist gesperrt. Ich nehme nicht an, dass deine IP-Adresse schon gesperrt ist. Weil das natürlich jetzt, da wir dazu aufgerufen haben, ist es ja offensichtlich, dass jeder jetzt mal kurz rumgespielt hat. Aber das heißt ja nicht, dass derjenige jetzt grundsätzlich böswillig ist. Das Sperren der IP-Adressen ist wirklich nur dann, wenn man sieht, dass einer unter derselben IP-Adresse viele Änderungen, vielleicht sogar in vielen verschiedenen Artikeln macht. Das könnte sich auch um einen Robott handeln zum Beispiel. Keine Ahnung. Spammein nicht ein Problem? Noch nicht, ne?
Den kleineren habe ich vor kurzem gehört, dass jemand versucht hat zu spammen. Aber dann haben wir halt einfach das alles mit Malviers rückgängig gemacht. Und ja, das ist auch keine große Sache. Was höchstens ein Problem sein könnte, ist eher mehr so subtiler Spam. Aber dafür haben die Spammer dann meistens irgendwie nicht genug Ausdauer. Also meistens ist es einfach plumpe Sachen, dass einfach bei den Weblinks halt einfach ein Link auf bestimmte Werbe für solche Seiten eingesetzt werden von irgendwelchen Leuten und so. Und das fällt natürlich sofort auf. Also das ist dann auch ganz schön wieder draußen.
Es gibt aber auch digitale Hausmeister, den Pybot und den Zwobot vor allem, die einfach automatische Programme sind, die eigentlich die ganze Zeit nichts anderes machen, als sich die Wikipedia durchzulesen. Und die sind trainiert auf bestimmte Dinge, die sich dort finden, wie zum Beispiel, wenn das sie ja auch nicht in der allgemein akzeptierten Formatierungsregel gemacht ist und ändert dann sozusagen von Fettdruck auf Kursivdruck.
Hatten wir Faschismus in der Staatsform der Wikipedia?
Nee. Also das ist ja kein Faschismus. Erstmal kann man ja die Änderung des Bots genauso rückgängig machen und es werden natürlich auch nur die Änderungen automatisch durchgeführt, die wirklich allgemein akzeptiert sind. So. Und letztlich würde jetzt so ein Spammer da herkommen und irgendwie seine URL dahinter lassen, dann würde man den mit diesen Bots genauso rausfingern können und das würde dann auch geschehen. Aber es ist ja offensichtlich noch kein großes Problem. Man muss das immer im Hinterkopf haben, aber bislang...
Wird es dann irgendwann die Kriege zwischen den Robotern geben, zwischen den digitalen Bürokraten, die damals Autos fanden?
Ich glaube, was man immer wieder sagen muss, ist, klar, man redet jetzt ein bisschen mehr über die Problemfälle und was so passieren kann, aber im Endeffekt, ich würde sagen, ein bisschen kann man die Wikipedia fast als Insel der Glückseligen im Internet sehen. Wenn man sich bestimmte Foren anguckt oder das Usenet, wo es dann drunter und drüber geht und die Leute sich versuchen, die Köpfe virtuell einzuschlagen, da sind wir doch noch ein gutes Stück weit von weg und das ist doch auch ganz angenehm. Also klar, es gibt immer wieder heiße Diskussionen und Leute, die sich vielleicht auch am zumal ein bisschen lieber in die Gurgel gehen würden, aber die allermeisten Änderungen und Bearbeitungen und Diskussionen sind sehr produktiv, sehr, sehr positiv, weil ich glaube, das Wikipedia-Anzeigenprojekt ist, was vor allem die Leute anspricht, die sich produktiv betätigen wollen, die eine Menge Wissen sich angeeignet haben und Lust haben, mit anderen Leuten, die auch produktiv an einem Werk schaffen wollen, sich für sich zu beteiligen. Deswegen haben wir immer ein gutes Diskussionsklima.
Hier ist Chaosradio 91. In der Wikipedia ist sogar, wenn man auf Chaosradio, also nach Chaosradio sucht, da featuren sich ein gewisser Tim Pritloff selbst. Ja, also da ist ein Link, da kann ich draufklicken. Und da ist dann Tim Pritloff, da steht dann bestimmt sowas wie...
Nein, das ist meine Benutzerseite.
Ach so.
Das ist einfach mein Account in der Wikipedia. Ich hab das da auch nicht reingeschrieben.
Natürlich nicht, nein, nein.
Kannst du nachschlagen, das ist doch nicht mein Account. Da steht eine Alpia drin, nicht meines.
Das glaube ich, dein Pia, oder was?
Ja, also das zeigt halt ganz schön, also worüber wir gerade gesprochen haben, ist halt, wie geht man eigentlich dieses Ändern ran? Und wie lernt man überhaupt erst mal an dem Projekt Wikipedia, an dieser Encyclopädie teilzunehmen? Es gibt da also einerseits diese Sachen mit dem zufälligen Artikel, wo man halt einfach mal so schön rumblättern kann in der Encyclopädie. Aber es gibt natürlich auch viele potenzielle Baustellen. Die sind auch unter Wikipedia Doppelpunkt Baustelle verzeichnet und auch noch an vielen anderen Stellen sind halt Artikel aufgeführt, die eben nach Meinung von Betrachtern unvollständig, offensichtlich inkorrekt, aber da wissen sie halt jetzt auch nicht besser, oder könnte man nochmal was machen.
Der neutrale Standpunkt wird vielleicht nicht gerade ganz gewahrt.
Genau, also wo es halt irgendwelche Sachen gibt, die eben nicht so sind. Es gibt auch verwaiste Artikel, die vielleicht an sich etwas vollkommen korrekt beschreiben, aber auf die schlicht kein anderer Artikel zeigt.
Oder es gibt Artikel, die doppelt existieren, unter zwei verschiedenen Namen sozusagen, wo jemand dachte, zu einem bestimmten Thema gibt es noch keinen Artikel und hat unter einem bestimmten Titel das sozusagen angelegt.
Ahja, Ars Electronica und Ars Electronica Center fällt mir da gerade ein.
Ja, genau sowas. Und das wäre natürlich schön, wenn sich dann mal jemand finden würde, der das dann wieder zusammenführt.
Ja und ich finde es auch ganz schön, wenn sich mal jemand finden würde, den Rumänien-Artikel um das 5 zu 1 gegen Deutschland.
Viele hat doch da gerade wieder ein paar neue Informationen ausgefragt. Viele?
Ah.
Ja, ich hab nur die Information, dass ich nicht weiß, warum sich Rumänien 1950 nicht zur WM gemeldet hat.
Vielleicht weil sie damals schon geahnt haben, dass Deutschland kein Gegner für sie ist.
Ja, die sind auch an der Qualifikation gescheitert. 1970 ein kleines Erfolgserlebnis.
Wo rülst denn das jetzt hier aus?
Krobgpeter in der ersten Runde ausgeschieden. Da gibt es stads.fußball-forum.de Da steht leider so Zeug über Fussi drin.
Aber es sind auch diverse Fußballfans in der Wikipedia vertreten.
Das heißt, die brüskieren wir jetzt gerade, während wir uns darüber lustig machen.
Brüskieren?
Mit Fakten? Mit Fakten brüskieren eben, also ich bitte dich. Der Tschecher hat uns ja auch abgeledert. Aber der ist ja am Samstag unser Freund. Holger. Entschuldigung.
Aber man kann generell sagen, dass es faszinierend ist, zu wie vielen Themen sich Leute finden und was schreiben. Wir haben verschiedene Portale, also das sind sozusagen untereinstiegs Seiten zu bestimmten speziellen Themen. Und ich kann hier mal kurz ein bisschen vorlesen. Antike, Astronomie und Raumfahrt, Bahn, Brandenburg, Chemie, Computerspiele, deutsche Literatur, Eishockey, Essen und Trinken, Ethnologie, Feuerwehr, Film, Fotografie, Geschichte, Grafentheorie und so weiter und so fort. Bis man dann zum Schluss landet bei Thüringen, Umwelt- und Naturschutz, Wirtschaft und Zusammenleben, Partnerschaft und Sexualität.
Oh, Sexualität, Sexcells.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall ein spannendes Thema, wo man ganz, ganz viele spannende Dinge zu schreiben kann. Und wo ich auch stolz drauf bin, also, weißt man nebenbei, ja, gehst du bei Google Clitoris ein, dann bist du bei uns. Und da bin ich ganz stolz, weil das natürlich ein Begriff ist, der ganz heiß um Kämpfe ist, wahrscheinlich von allen möglichen vorne Seiten. Und ja, sogar da wäre es schon in die Top 10 geschafft bei Google.
Eins, zwei, drei, ne, ne, ne. Doch, Wikipedia, dritte.
Dritte Stelle.
Nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht.
Ja, und da finde ich es natürlich cool, wenn halt pubertierende Schüler im Internet sich rumtreiben und auf der Suche sind, bin ich auf jeden Fall froh, wenn sie bei uns landen, als wenn sie auf irgendwelchen Hardcore-Porno-Seiten...
Ja, aber sollte man denn nicht vielleicht wenigstens vor die Clitoris-Seite so einen Dialer programmieren?
Hier nur ab 18?
Ja, genau. Dann tippen sie OK in dieses Fenster. Einfach so zum Spaß.
Nein, das sollte man natürlich nicht machen, Holger. Das weißt du doch ganz genau. Aber das bebe ist.
Das macht man nicht.
Das ist alles nicht fein. Na gut, dann Frames. Damit plackt man diese Windows-Benutzer noch mehr, als ohnehin schon plackt sind.
Braucht ihr eigentlich Hilfe?
Auf jeden Fall.
Jetzt mal abgesehen von Leuten, die natürlich Artikel schreiben, die Artikel editieren, was ja jeder machen kann, braucht ihr auch qualifizierte Hilfe?
Wer braucht die nicht?
Mir geht's gut.
Unsere Autoren sind ja alle qualifiziert, auch wenn sie vielleicht nicht...
Vielleicht irgendwelche Programmierer, irgendwelche Grafiker.
Ja klar, was wir auf jeden Fall brauchen, sind natürlich Illustrationen und Leute, die mit dem Fotoapparat unterwegs sind und Sachen dokumentieren. Da können wir auf jeden Fall noch mehr als genug Leute brauchen.
Schöne Fotos von Sachen, die auch wirklich genau das zeigen, was halt erklärt wird. Im Softwarebereich, es gibt auch viele Leute, die jetzt nicht unbedingt an der Wikisoftware selber mitprogrammieren, sondern die kleinere Tools bereitstellen. Erwähnenswert ist da zum Beispiel dieser automatische Kartengenerator. Wenn man also jetzt über irgendeinen, also ich hab zum Beispiel vor ein paar Tagen hab ich mal einen Artikel angelegt über Klein-Mach-No. Weil das war halt noch nicht drin und ich war gerade in Klein-Mach-No und dachte ich mir so Klein-Mach-No muss jetzt auch in die Wikibli. Bin ich erstmal losgegangen, hab geguckt, wie legt man denn überhaupt einen Artikel an über einen Ort. Was nämlich ganz erwähnenswert ist, es gibt für verschiedene Arten, von Artikeln sogenannte Formatvorlagen. Das ist sozusagen so ein Grundgerüst, wo man schon mal sehen kann, welche Informationen denn man so eigentlich haben will. Also mit so grundsätzlichen Statistiken, die Gemeinde ID, wie viele Einwohner, wie ist so die Dichte. Das findet man dann noch häufig auf den Gemeinde-Homepages. Das hab ich mir dann alles aus dem Web zusammengesucht und hab eben diesen Artikel angelegt. Und jetzt hab ich schon wieder vergessen, was ich eigentlich erzählen wollte.
Der automatische Kartengenerator.
Ah, genau, der automatische Kartengenerator. Man möchte natürlich auch noch eine Karte haben. Und da gibt es eben einen Kartengenerator, den Link, den befindet sich auch in der Wikipedia. Dann geht man halt drauf und sagt, welcher Ort soll es denn sein? Wikipedia und Klein-Mach-No habe ich dann eingegeben. Dann kriegt man so eine Deutschlandkarte und dann ist da so ein roter Punkt an der richtigen Stelle, sodass man halt sieht, wo das ist. Ähnliches gibt es dann für Regionen von Ländern, Ländern überhaupt, Kontinentübersichten und so weiter. Und diese Karte, die halt dieses Tool ausspuckt, ist dann eben auch der entsprechende Lizenz. Sprich, kann man einfach nehmen und in die Wikipedia einführen und alles ist prima.
Genau, und solche kleinen Tools können wir natürlich auch ganz viel gebrauchen. Und Leute generell, wenn jemand fähig ist, gute PHP-Programme zu schreiben, klar, die Wikipediasoftware ist auch frei, kann jeder benutzen und erweitern. Und ja, da sind auch ganz viele Sachen noch, die man da bestimmt verbessern und erweitern kann.
20.11 Chaosradio 91 und eigentlich wollten wir über Nachschlagen im Web reden, im Allgemeinen und im Besonderen über die Wikipedia, aber im Momentan reden wir im Besonderen nur noch über die Wikipedia und im Allgemeinen erst recht und genauso auch mit euch unter 0331 70 97 110. Würden wir ganz gerne auch mit euch über die Wikipedia reden, denn das ist eine Sendung zum Anrufen und davon lebt diese Sendung. Jeder, der was zu sagen hat, der wird auch gehört. Vorausgesetzt, wir sind der Meinung, dass irgendwer was zu sagen hat. Tim, was mich noch kurz interessieren würde, du sagst, du warst in klein Machno und hast dir gedacht, hey, das steht noch nicht in der Wikipedia drin. Läufst du da mit dem Laptop die ganze Zeit rum und UMTS? Oder gibt es jetzt auch zum Mitnehmen die Wikipedia jetzt?
Naja, in dem Fall hatte ich schon so WLAN beim Freund, aber grundsätzlich gibt es tatsächlich eine Offline-Version von der Wikipedia für so mobile Windows, wie heißt dieses Betriebssystem? Windows CE. Und dann kann man sich sozusagen einen aktuellen Stand der Wikipedia so zum lokalen Rumklicken, zum Offline-Rumklicken runterladen. Das funktioniert auch auf diesem modernen Telefon. So Ericsson P900 habe ich es schon mal laufen gesehen und ungefähr 100 Megabyte groß. Also wenn man so eine Flash-Erweiterungskarte hat oder so, dann geht das schon wunderbar und dann braucht man eben auch kein Internet. Dann kann man zwar nicht ändern, aber man hat im Prinzip so einen Per-Anhalter durch die Galaxis. Also zumindest einen Per-Anhalter durch den Planeten Erde.
Übrigens möchte ich an dieser Stelle anmerken, dass ich meinen Pocket PC nun doch nicht mehr verkaufen möchte. Aber du wolltest den eh nicht haben, Tim, oder?
Nee, ich glaube nicht.
Ist aber Bluetooth drin.
Bisschen noch los, oder?
Ja, natürlich. 0331 77 97 110. Wir würden ganz gerne mal eure Lobhude leihen auf die Wikipedia. Aber nicht immer nur unsere Lobhude leihen. Also, welche Erfahrungen habt ihr damit gemacht? Beteiligt ihr euch und wenn ja, wie? Und hat es für euch vielleicht schon mal geholfen? Hat es dir mal geholfen, Tim?
Mir? Oh ja, schon mehrfach. Also es gibt einfach, ich finde vor allem so grundlegende, einfache Begriffe sind teilweise so erstaunlich gut beschrieben, dass man es einfach versteht. Medienkompetenz zum Beispiel.
Ist so schön beschrieben oder hat es dir genutzt?
Dann in dem Moment nützt es einem natürlich, weil wenn man zum Beispiel gerade was weiß ich, einen Vortrag vorbereitet, wo es dann eben auch immer so um Begriffe geht, man weiß schon, naja, grundsätzlich hat es damit zu tun. Dann ist man sich nicht so richtig sicher, ob man das jetzt eigentlich wissenschaftlich korrekt auch verwendet oder ob man nicht gerade Stuss redet. Dann kann man das zumindest erst mal gegenprüfen. Ist natürlich für Schüler auch großartig zum Nachschlagen. Ich kenne viele jüngere Leute, die meinen, Wikipedia super, hilft mir bei meinen Aufsätzen, hilft mir einfach in der Schule, einfach als Hintergrundmaterial. Und im Prinzip erlaubt die Lizenz ja auch die Übernahme des Textes.
Aber das haben wir jetzt nicht gesagt.
Natürlich nicht. Am Telefon begrüßen wir Ralf aus dem Saarland.
Hallo. Ja, hallo, guten Abend. Was ich jetzt zu der Sendung beitragen wollte, ist folgendes. Also ich finde Wikipedia natürlich auch ganz großartig, beteilige mich da auch selber mit dran und verlinke auch, wo ich kann eigentlich immer darauf. Aber das Thema der Sendung ist ja Nachschlagewerke. Und es gibt ja auch noch Nachschlagewerke, die sogar auf Wikibasis aufbauen, die aber nicht Wikipedia sind. Also ich denke hier zum Beispiel an das Linux-Wiki.
Das Linux-Wiki macht was?
Erklär ruhig.
Das Linux-Wiki, das ist halt anders als Wikipedia. Schreibt das halt keine Lexikon-Artikel. Das ist nicht das Ziel im Linux-Wiki, sondern man befasst sich einfach ganz allgemein mit dem Thema Linux. Also man hat einen engeren Fokus als in Wikipedia, wo ja prinzipiell ich zu allem was schreiben kann, sondern hier geht es halt um Linux. Aber dafür halt einen weiteren Blick halt, was die Art der Texte angeht, die da entstehen. Also das ist halt mehr so klassisches Wiki, will ich es mal nennen. Und da habe ich halt auch enzyklopädische Ansätze zwar, aber ich habe vielleicht auch einfach mal nur eine Linkliste oder irgendwie eine Bauanleitung oder wie ich irgendwas installiere und solche Sachen.
Aber alles nur bezogen auf Linux.
Das ist jetzt in diesem Fall bezogen auf Linux.
Aber will ich das nicht in der Enzyklopädie mit drin haben? Also will ich nicht nur eine Enzyklopädie, wo alles drin steht?
Es ist ja nicht alles nur Enzyklopädie. Also es gibt ja auch noch andere Formen oder einfach andere Textsorten, sage ich mal. Oder es gibt auch, man kann ja mit dem Wiki auch ganz wunderbar zusammenarbeiten, ohne dass da jetzt ein Lexikon-Artikel bei rausspringt. Und das ist was, was im Linux-Wiki gemacht wird und was ja auch in den ganzen vielen anderen Wikis halt gemacht wird. Und das Wikipedia ist jetzt halt ein Spezialfall eines Wikis, nämlich gerade das Wiki, das halt Lexikon-Artikel schreibt und das sehr erfolgreich.
Mhm, das stimmt. Also es gibt, also linuxwiki.de ist das, kann man gleich nochmal die URL dazu sagen.
Genau, ja.
Das ist ein Moin Moin Wiki, was ich halt, wie du schon korrekt beschrieben hast.
Das gefällt mir, weil ich auch morgens öfter mal sende.
Ja, Moin Moin ist so eins der populäreren Wikisysteme, die so verwendet werden. Und es gibt auch noch ein englisches, das ist so ähnlich, das wirst du wahrscheinlich auch kennen. Ich glaube linuxquestions.org. Es gibt verschiedenste, also User Documentation generell. Das ist einfach auch, das Wiki ist einfach wunderbar. Wir haben jetzt auch gerade hier bei dem MacHackers hier in Berlin auch gerade angefangen, auf Basis von dem Media Wiki unter MacHackers.de auch ein Wiki aufzusetzen, was eben ähnlichen Dokumentationszweck hat, wie eben dieses LinuxWiki.de, bloß eben dann eben für die Macintosh-Seite der Welt. Und so gibt es gerade ganz viele Projekte, die so durchstarten.
Genau, man kann ja noch ein paar andere vielleicht nennen. Also die wirklich ganz großen in der deutschen Sprache sind zum Beispiel das Jura-Wiki, also das sind für Juristen ganz viele Jurastudenten, die sich da tummeln und sich gegenseitig austauschen. Es gibt ein Mozilla-Wiki, es gibt ein deutsches Software-Entwickler-Wiki, also da gibt es ganz viele, wo dann auch ein bisschen mehr der Community-Gedanke vielleicht noch mehr am Vordergrund steht als bei uns. Also wo das dann auch einfach um die gegenseitige Kommunikation über ein bestimmtes Thema geht, nicht nur darum, wie ein bestimmter Sachverhalt jetzt neutral dargestellt werden soll oder so, sondern einfach, ja, so das Zwischenmenschliche, noch ein bisschen mehr betont wird vielleicht.
Das ist jetzt ganz interessant, dass du das Jura-Wiki ausgerechnet erwähnt hast, weil das hatte ich vor ja, etwas über anderthalb Jahren angeregt durch das Linux-Wiki wiederum ins Leben gerufen. Und das ist jetzt halt gerade was, wo wir jetzt auch schon gesagt haben, ja gut, also ein Rechtslexikon brauchen wir nicht schreiben, das macht ja Wikipedia viel besser als wir. Und wir versuchen jetzt mit dem Jura-Wiki gerade halt alles andere zu machen, was halt nicht Lexikon ist, aber mit Jura zu tun hat. Ich hab mich auch schon an der Seite da beteiligt und hatte auch versucht, da schon diesen Aspekt mal mit reinzubringen. Also, weil das ist ja auch ein bisschen was, ich meine, das ist natürlich toll, dass jetzt Wiki durch Wikipedia so bekannt wird. Und das ist ja jetzt in wirklich allen Medien schon drin. Aber was dabei oft ein bisschen verloren geht, ist halt, dass ja Wiki noch viel mehr ist, als nur Lexikon schreiben. Und das sieht man halt bei diesen Sachen, wie halt Linux, Wiki, Jura, Wiki und andere. Wikis sind ja Tausende, die es da gibt. Dass man halt drum herum noch ganz viel mit Wiki machen kann.
Ja, aber ich denke mal, um Menschen an Wiki an sich heranzuführen, ist die Wikipedia, glaube ich, das angenehmste, weil du da eben wirklich in deinem Alltag verhaftet bist. Also selbst als normaler User.
Die haben natürlich auch den Riesenvorteil, weil sie ja wirklich alles als Thema haben. Dass auch jeder Nutzer die Seite findet, von der er Ahnung hat und auf der er mitschreiben kann. Und ich glaube, das ist vielleicht auch so ein Teil des Geheimnisses des Erfolges von Wikipedia.
Ja klar.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum wir das jetzt in den Mittelpunkt gestellt haben. Du hast schon recht, uns geht es hier um Nachschlagewerke und da gibt es eben viel Spezifisches, aber es gibt eben auch einiges, was so ein bisschen mehr den Meta-Gedanken hat und das ist eben Wikipedia. Aber im Prinzip kann es ja auch jeder nehmen und damit sein eigenes Ding machen.
Vielen Dank Ralf. Und eine gute Nacht noch. Ja, danke, gleichfalls. Ihr könnt natürlich auch gerne weiter anrufen, wenn ihr euch äußern wollt. 0331 70 97 110 an der Fritz-Hotline, wie immer der Einbeinige, der euch gerne ins Studio durchstellt.
Wir sehen uns dann wieder.
Wenn Fritz in Potsdam, dann 102, 6.
Eine Minute nachher zwölf.
Fritz Info.
Mit dem Wetter heute Nacht ist es nur gering bewölkt. Die Temperaturen sinken auf neun bis fünf Grad. Morgen ist es dann heiter bis wolkig und die Temperaturen steigen auf warme 23 Grad. Und jetzt steigen hier die Meldungen mit Matthias Kerkov.
Guten Abend. Die US-Luftwaffe hat am Abend der Neustellungen von Aufständischen in der irakischen Stadt Fallujah angegriffen. Augenzeugen berichteten, dass Munitionslage getroffen worden seien. US-Präsident Bush hat weitere Militäraktionen angekündigt. Der Weltsicherheitsrat hat einstimmig eine Resolution zum Schutz vor Anschlägen mit Massenvernichtungswaffen beschlossen. Sie verpflichtet alle UN-Mitgliedstaaten zu gesetzlichen Maßnahmen, damit Terroristen nicht in den Besitz von Massenvernichtungswaffen gelangen können. In Berlin haben Vertreter aus 55 Ländern über einen Aktionsplan gegen den Antisemitismus beraten. Außenminister Fischer forderte die Staaten auf, sich gemeinsam mit allen Formen des Antisemitismus auseinanderzusetzen. Das Auswärtige Amt hat vor Reisen in den Süden Thailands gewarnt. Dort hat die Polizei bei den bislang schwersten Unruhen mehr als 100 aufständische Moslems getötet. Die moslemische Minderheit in Thailand fühlt sich von der Regierung diskriminiert. Und zum Sport, die deutsche Fußballnationalmannschaft hat in Bucharest ein Länderspiel gegen Rumänien klar mit 1 zu 5 verloren. Oliver Kahn nach dem Spiel.
Ja, für dieses Spiel gibt es überhaupt keine Entschuldigung. Es ist auch egal, ob die Mannschaft so noch nie zusammengespielt hat. Es spielt auch keine Rolle, dass viele Spieler kurz vorm Spiel noch ausgefallen sind, verletzt. Ich meine, man muss vorsichtig sein mit solchen Aussagen, aber das war schon eine absolute Blamage und ein sehr, sehr großer Rückschlag.
Besser spielten die Frauen. Die Frauen bzw. das Frauenteam der EM-Qualifikation gewann gegen die Ukraine mit 6 zu 0. Und wie berichtet, bei der All-Socke-Weltmeisterschaft gab es für Deutschland eine erwartete Niederlage gegen die Gastgeber Tschechien. Das Spiel endete 1 zu 5. Der Verkehr auf Fritz und der Sean berühren die RBB Verkehrsleitstelle und sehen es gibt dort keine Meldungen. Wir wünschen eine gute Fahrt.
Wir haben hier auch gar keine Verkehrsleitstelle.
Vielen Dank, Matthias Gerkhoff.
3 Minuten nach halb 12.
Die Mayday 2004. Chris Liebing. Superpitcher. TofTok vs Lena. Und vielen, vielen mehr.
Achtung, die letzten, die letzten Karten für die Mayday.
Diese Woche auf Fritz.
Die Mayday Special. Live übertragen aus der Dortmunder Westfalenhalle auf allen Frequenzen von Fritz. Freitag ab 20 Uhr. Die ganze Nacht und im Radio.
Ihr Chaosradio 91 auf Fritz. Eigentlich wollten wir über das Web, Nachschlagwerke im Web reden. Ja, und zwar über das eine. Ich hab dann noch eine Frage hätte ich noch, um noch mal kurz zurückzuspringen, mein lieber Kurt. Du hattest ja gesagt, dass Fotos, also Fotos ja rechten unterliegen und darum nicht einfach so veröffentlicht werden können. Jetzt sehe ich in dem Clitoris Artikel ein Foto, das ja dann offensichtlich selbst fotografiert sein muss und da steht, dass du dieses Foto da reingesetzt hast.
Ich habe das aus der englischen Wikipedia genommen.
Ich gehe zu McDonalds auch nur wegen der kleinen Geschenke, die es da gibt.
Na, aber da hat sich anscheinend wirklich jemand gefunden, der gesehen hat, dass da eine Lücke ist, dass da was dokumentiert werden muss.
Da ist allerdings eine Lücke...
.dokumentiert werden muss. Und hat das in die englische Wikipedia eingestellt und ich dachte, ja, in der deutschen passt es auch.
Stimmt, passt.
Also, kann man gleich noch mal erwähnen.
Gibt es schon Artikel zum Wort Zote eigentlich?
Ist aber auf jeden Fall ein Begriff. Also würde von daher wahrscheinlich auch, wenn es gut geschrieben ist, seinen Platz finden in der Wikipedia.
Ist auch noch nicht drin.
Aber Bilder sind halt ein gutes Beispiel, wo man eben auch aktiv beitragen kann, wenn Text einem nicht so liegt, aber eher vielleicht die Fotografie. Dann kann man eben einfach mal schauen, wo fehlt etwas. Und dann kann man eben das auch mit Fotos, die man selber gemacht hat oder von denen man weiß, dass sie frei sind, kann man die eben beitragen.
Wie ist denn das? Weiß das einer von euch? Also wenn ich jetzt ein Markenprodukt abfotografiere, habe ich dann die Bildrechte oder ist das also?
Das ist schwierig.
Tempotaschen natürlich abfotografieren.
Da gab es schon Leute, die haben irgendwie, weil sie einen Zug auf einem Foto von einem Bahnhof hatten, einen Zettel gekriegt von einer deutschen Bahn, dass sie da das Produkt abbilden und...
Aber man kann es natürlich nachmalen. Das ist dann wiederum urheberrechtlich, soweit ich weiß, gedeckt durch Interpretation. Das habe ich auch schon mal irgendwo gesehen, aber ich habe jetzt kein gutes Beispiel. Bei irgendeiner Firma war das tatsächlich so.
Ja, aber diese Urheberrechtsproblematiken, das sind so Sachen, wo ich zum Beispiel persönlich immer gar keine große Lust hab, mich mit auseinanderzusetzen. So die Feinheiten, was darf man, was darf man nicht. Also ich bin da vielleicht auch eher eine ängstliche Natur und sag so, okay, im Zweifelsfall vielleicht lieber nicht machen. Aber klar, sein mutig. Ja, das ist halt dann vielleicht an dem Stelle vielleicht dann doch ein bisschen Vorsicht auch angebracht. Aber wenn jetzt uns vielleicht gerade irgendwie ein Anwalt zuhört mit Spezialgebiet Urheberrecht, kann er ja gerne mal anrufen und uns das erklären.
Ja, und angerufen wird unter 0331 70 97 110. Die Wikipedia gibt es auch gesprochen. Hab ich mir sagen lassen?
Ja, nicht komplett. Aber es gibt so ein paar Leute, die mal damit angefangen haben. Das ist eher erst mal so Proof of Concept, würde ich sagen. Wir können ja mal kurz einen einspielen.
Area 51 aus Wikipedia der Freien Enzyklopädie. Area 51 ist ein militärisches Sperrgebiet im südlichen Nevada USA. Innerhalb des großen Luftwaffenübungsgeländes Nellis befindet sich eine nochmals extra gesicherte militärische Anlage, deren bloße Existenz von der amerikanischen Regierung bis vor wenigen Jahren geheim gehalten wurde. Fest steht, dass die Air Force dort neue experimentelle Flugzeuge testet, um den Komplex ranken sich jedoch auch die verschiedensten Verschwörungstheorien in Sachen Außerirdische. Geografie. Area 51 ist ein Gebiet von etwa 155 Quadratkilometern in linken Ground in Nevada. Im größten Teil davon macht das Emigrant Valley aus, das von den Umeen verbringt.
Das darf aber auch nur von Betrunkenden vorgelesen werden.
Also hier wäre es auf jeden Fall für professionelle Sprecher eine schöne Möglichkeit, ihre Freizeit zu gestalten. Gut lesen ist natürlich auch eine Kunst. Gut sprechen und trotzdem finde ich das sehr interessant, weil es natürlich die Wikipedia dann den Leuten zugänglich machen kann, die die Wikipedia nicht so ohne weiteres lesen können.
Eine blinde, weil ewig so eine Brei-Tastatur, da wirst du ja auch wahnsinnig.
Es gibt ja auch Hörbücher, also man kann auch im Auto...
Aber Hörbücher sind ja für Faule, dachte ich einfach.
Ja, warum soll ja auch die gesprochene Wikipedia nicht für Faule sein?
Ist doch nicht toll, dass man auf der Fahrt von Berlin nach München die Wikipedia zählt.
Ja, da kann man sich mal irgendwie das Wesen der Blattschneiderameisen erklären lassen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sich das positiv auf die Verkehrssicherheit auswirkt.
Naja, ich meine, ob man nun irgendwie sich Kritophränen vorlesen lässt oder die Blattschneiderameisen. Das ist ja letztlich Wurst, wen es interessiert.
Aber das ist halt das Tolle, dass die Lizenz halt ermöglicht, dass neue Projekte sprießen und gedeihen, die die Texte nehmen und damit ganz andere Sachen machen. Also zum Beispiel die gesprochene Wikipedia, was ein anderes Projekt zum Beispiel ist, was zurzeit entsteht und sehr aktiv ist, sind die Wiki Reader, wo Leute sich hingesetzt haben und uns zu einem bestimmten Themengebiet geguckt haben, welche Artikel haben wir schon, was fehlt noch. Und ja, das versucht haben zu komplettieren und das in gedruckter Form rausgeben. Also erstmal als eine normale PDF-Datei, die man sich runterladen kann. Und ja, im Endeffekt überlegen wir zurzeit, ob wir das auch in Druck geben. Und ja, dass man das sozusagen schön, die Wikipedia fürs Regal hat.
Also nicht die gesamte Wikipedia, sondern bislang ist das Projekt sozusagen immer ein Auszug zu einem bestimmten Themenbereich, was es bereits gibt. Das erste war glaube ich Schweden, richtig?
Genau, Internet ist jetzt das nächste.
Was auch gerade im Interesse ist, weil es gibt eine Konferenz, die demnächst stattfinden wird. Das kann man auch nochmal erwähnen. Ich habe jetzt den Termin nicht genau im Kopf, ich schaue gleich nochmal nach. Die Wizard of Oz, also so ein Spiel mit dem Titel des Films des Bekannten.
Das ist der 10. bis 12.
Juni. Genau, findet statt im Berliner Kongresscenter am Alexanderplatz. Und dort geht es eben um solche Themen, wie die Wissensalmende, um freie Systeme, freies Wissen im Allgemeinen. Dort wird es auch, soweit ich weiß, einen Vortrag geben von dem Jimbo Wales.
Genau.
Und so heißt er, Jimbo Wales, den Gründer der Wikipedia, der sich schon richtig freut, weil er noch nie in Europa war. Und dann hier gleich so eine ganze Tour hat, wo er dann rumgereicht wird. Und ja, das könnte auf jeden Fall sehr interessant sein. Und unter anderem, das hab ich so am Rande mitbekommen, ist das Motivation, jetzt für diesen nächsten Wikirider auch fertig zu werden bis zu dieser Konferenz. Mal sehen, ob das klappt. Auf jeden Fall kann man dazu beitragen. Und zwar gar nicht so sehr, indem man schreibt, sondern indem man einfach nur auswählt, was ist ein relevantes Thema? Was ist ein guter Artikel in der Wikipedia, der dort rein muss? Und ist sicherlich auch insofern wertvoll, als dass, wenn man das in diesem Kontext so zusammensieht, also nur relevante Themen gruppiert, man noch ganz anders auf die Artikel als solche blickt. Haben die eigentlich alle einen konsistenten Stil? Erzählt das eine korrekte Geschichte? Oder sind die jetzt so unterschiedlich, dass der Fluss, der sich durch das Zusammenstellen ergibt, unter Umständen abreißt oder so?
Einen Anrufer haben wir. 0331 77 97 110 ist die Nummer unter der ihr euch beteiligen könnt im Chaosradio auf Fritz. Hallo Mario aus Berlin.
Ich wollte mal von euch wissen, warum ihr eigentlich immer abswingt, wenn die Rede auf Google kommt.
Na, weil das nicht so sehr das Thema ist. Google ist halt eine Suchmaschine und nicht so sehr ein Nachschlagewerk. Es ist ja nicht so, dass Google selber Inhalt bereitstellt, sondern nur Inhalt durchsucht und darauf verweist. Das ist ja schon ein ganz anderer Ansatz. Das ist richtig.
Aber nun ist es so, ich persönlich kann da nur aus meiner Erfahrung berichten natürlich. Ich bin Liebhaber von alten Fahrzeugen, alten Autos, alten Motorrädern etc. Und suche auch oft speziell dazu Wissen. Also wie zum Beispiel funktioniert eine Lucas Gleichstrom Dynamo 6 Volt, der in den 50er Jahren gebaut wurde. Würde ich denn sowas bei Wikipedia finden?
Du könntest sowas bei Wikipedia selber reinschreiben.
Ja, mittlerweile könnte ich das auch, weil ich selber genug dazu gefunden habe. Aber gerade wenn es um solche Spezialgebiete geht oder wenn ich für mein Studium recherchiere, dann bin ich halt auf solche Suchmaschinen eigentlich eher angewiesen als auf Nachschlagewerke. Weil diese Suchmaschinen doch wesentlich umfassender eben das Netz durchsuchen, was natürlich ärgerlich ist. Die Tatsache, die ich auch schon erwähnt habe, dass bei solchen Suchmaschinen immer, sag ich mal, 98% der Treffer unbrauchbar sind und man erst mal eine ganze Weile filtern muss und an seinen Suchkriterien feiern muss, bis man dann halt einen Artikel gefunden hat, der einem wirklich dann auch die Informationen verschafft, die man braucht. Interessanter wäre es doch eben das Netz, was ja an sich schon da ist und die Webseiten, die ja allgemein auch im Internet sozusagen kursieren und als feste IPs auch zu erreichen sind. Ob man denn da nicht eine Struktur reinbringt und jetzt nicht, wie ihr jetzt gerade auch beschreibt, eine Wikipedia, eine eigene Plattform baut.
Das ist alles richtig, was du sagst. Allerdings ist es natürlich auch so, dass die vielen Homepages, wo du solche Informationen findest, nicht so umfangreich auf andere relevante und verbundene Informationen verlinken, weil man das eben auch nicht selber ändern kann. Wenn du schon ein großes Wissen zusammengetragen hast, was hält dich davon ab, das in die Wikipedia zu tragen? Es gibt da zum Beispiel die Themenliste Straßenverkehr, es gibt einen Artikel zu Oldtimern und jemand hat sich, was ich weiß, auch schon bemüht, da irgendwie alte Straßenbahnmodelle irgendwie zu beschreiben. Warum soll nicht auch diese Information, die du schon gewonnen hast, dort hineinkommen? Und dann hat es eben auch den Vorteil, andere Leute können das wiederum ändern, ergänzen, können Links untereinander setzen und dadurch wächst das Ganze. Klar, solange diese Information in der Wikipedia nicht drin ist, dann muss man sich eben an andere Quellen bedienen. Aber der große Vorteil ist natürlich auch der Content, der in der Wikipedia entsteht, der steht dir auch frei zur Verwendung. Das heißt, du kannst dann damit auch noch was tun, nicht nur lesen, sondern eben auch verwenden. Das ist richtig. Und wenn du da so ein großes Wissen zusammengetragen hast, können wir dich da nur ermutigen, das dort mit einzubringen und mit den anderen Leuten, die dort am Forschen sind, zu kombinieren.
Ich verbringe ohnehin schon zu viel Zeit vorm Rechner, sicherlich wie die meisten Leute. Und die Zeit, die ich da vorbringe, versuche ich dann auch irgendwie produktiv zu nutzen, logischerweise. Was einem ohnehin schon schwer genug fällt, aufgrund dessen, dass das Internet ein dermaßen Wust von Werbung und Spam und Unsinn ist. Und man sich eigentlich ärgert bei jedem Suchbegriff, den man eingibt, dass man eigentlich so viel Unsinn findet. Was mich noch interessieren würde, ist, warum denn eigentlich diese ganzen anderen Suchmaschinen im Internet alles schlapp gemacht haben. Mehr oder weniger. Es ist ja eigentlich auch immer nur noch von Google die Rede. Wenn man irgendjemanden hört, Suchmaschinen, Internet, dann kommt als erstes immer der Begriff Google.
Das war lange Zeit auch einfach mal die schnellste und umfangreichste. Zumindest vom Look and Feel her auch die beste.
Sie ist es derzeit. Sie ist es immer noch. Ja, Google hat schlicht und ergreifend davon profitiert, dass das ein paar Leute gestartet haben, die das mit dem Internet einfach mal begriffen haben. Während sich die damals führende Suchmaschine Alta Vista vollständig verzettelt hat und dann dem Portalgedanken gefallen ist und irgendwie ihre einstmals schlanke Seite durch einen Werbungswust ersetzt hat, sind die Leute alle schnell mal auf Google rübergehuscht, weil einfach Google sich als Tool präsentiert hat und nicht so sehr als Werbeplattform. Mittlerweile haben sie ja auch ihren eigenen Weg von Werbung gefunden, der auch verhältnismäßig wenig stört als diese Google Adwords. Das ist einfach der Grund für den Erfolg. Bloß, dass jetzt alles über Google geht, hat natürlich auch so seine Probleme, weil man weiß eben auch nicht, welche Zensurmaßnahmen da sind. Es gibt dann diverse Konflikte mit Suchbegriff, was darf man dann finden, was bezahlen Leute dafür, dass etwas besser gefunden wird und nicht. Google hat an sich gute Credits und ist sicherlich derzeit kein großes Problem, aber sich jetzt auch nur auf ein einziges System zu verlassen, ist natürlich, ist einfach schwierig. Aber der Ansatz, also ich denke es ist wichtig, dass man im Nachschlagewerk und Suchmaschine weit auseinander hält. Natürlich ist eine Suchmaschine hilfreich, um verschiedene Nachschlagewerke überhaupt erst mal zu finden oder zu durchsuchen. Gar keine Frage. Wikipedia benutzt auch Google, um innerhalb von Wikipedia zu suchen, weil die derzeit gar nicht die Rechnerkapazität haben und Google das einfach ganz gut macht. Aber es ist halt etwas anderes, weil man kann die Dinge besser in Bezug setzen auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite ist der Ansatz ein anderer. Es geht darum zu erklären. Und wenn man eben nach einer Erklärung sucht, dann ist Wikipedia eine gute Adresse. Sucht man nach irgendetwas, dann nimmt man halt andere Quellen. Es ist ja nicht so, dass Wikipedia jetzt alles ersetzen soll.
Genug Suchmaschine. Mario! Wir würden uns freuen, wenn du wenigstens rudimentär dein Wissen in die Wikipedia schreiben würdest. Dann können andere ja dran weiterschreiben und du freust dich dann vielleicht über neues Wissen, was jemand anderes dazu geschrieben hat.
Na klar, aber es ist halt auch schade, dass in solchen wie Wikipedia eben, was man ja an diesem Hörbeitrag gehört hat, zum Thema Area 51, dass ja eigentlich ein sehr schwacher Abriss dessen ist, was es dazu eigentlich tatsächlich an Wissen und Daten...
Der Hörbeitrag ist insgesamt auch acht Minuten lang. Wir haben den dann ausgeblendet.
Das ist nur der erste Absatz. Ansonsten sei mutig, ja, mach es besser, wenn es dir nicht gefällt, du kannst halt selber mitmachen. Darum geht's.
Und dazu wollt ihr jetzt sicherlich auch die Leute animieren.
Genau, du bist der Erste.
Mario, danke für deinen Anruf. Und gute Nacht, tschüss. Und wir begrüßen Andreas aus Erlangen, hallo Andreas.
Na, tschüss Andreas.
Ich wollte das Problem ansprechen, dass manche Wikipedia-Artikel ein bisschen tendenziös sind. Also zum Beispiel den über Gerhard Schröder oder andere Politiker. Also die finde ich ein bisschen subjektiv.
Was meinst du denn mit tendenziös?
Ja, gerade dieser Gerhard Schröder Artikel ist relativ kritisch und ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass andere das nicht so sehen und dass der eine gewisse politische Meinung ausdrückt.
Na klar, wenn jemand schreibt, dann schreibt er natürlich immer subjektiv. Anders geht das ja gar nicht. Hast du schon mal darüber nachgedacht, selber eine Änderung einzubringen?
Nee, noch nicht.
Es gibt zum Beispiel auch zu jeder Seite in der Wikipedia immer, also zu jeder Seite gibt es immer die Möglichkeit, eine zugehörige Diskussionsseite zu füllen. Im Falle von Gerhard Schröder ist das auch vorhanden. Das heißt, dort unterhält man sich über den Inhalt der eigentlichen Seite. Und dort sieht man einerseits, wer sich überhaupt dazu äußert. Und wie. Und die Diskussionsseite ist relativ lang. Ich lese mir die jetzt mal nicht komplett durch. Aber unter Umständen, würde ich jetzt mal vermuten, kann das schon erhellend wirken, warum eigentlich eine Formulierung wie ist. Und du könntest dir auch mal die Versionshistorie anschauen von der Seite. Und auch das sagt schon eine ganze Menge aus, weil man mit einer Änderung, nicht nur die Änderung selbst, sondern bisweilen auch einen Kommentar, was die Motivation für diese Änderung war, dazu gestellt hat. Sodass man das eben auch ganz gut rauslesen kann.
Ich denke mal auch, dass gerade bei so Themen, die polarisieren, wie Politiker, Persönlichkeiten oder Dinge, die jetzt Religionen betreffen oder sonstige Geschichten, dass natürlich immer schwierig ist, das klassisch allen recht zu machen. Also der sozusagen objektivste Text wird sich in den Augen eines auf der anderen Seite befindlichen, immer tendenziös oder sonst wie.
Aber das ist halt das Ziel von uns, dass man nicht nur auf einen objektiven Standpunkt einnimmt, sondern wie gesagt einen neutralen Standpunkt. Und verschiedene Standpunkte sozusagen nebeneinander stehen können und man herauslesen kann, welche Meinungen zu einem bestimmten Sachweites halt gibt.
Ja, wahrscheinlich ist auch der Anspruch, einen neutralen Standpunkt zu haben, völlig unsinnig. Also man sollte von vornherein davon ausgehen, dass es eben bei Dingen, wo überhaupt Diskussionen aufkommen, einfach mehrere Standpunkte existieren und die auch zu irgendeiner Co-Existenz miteinander fähig sein müssen.
Andreas, vielen Dank. Interessant übrigens, wenn man bei der Gerhard Schröder-Seite in der Wikipedia guckt, ist ein bisschen biografische Daten. Gerhard Schröder ist Sohn einer Arbeiterfamilie, die aus insgesamt fünf Geschwistern bestand. Sein Vater, ein reisender Kirmesarbeiter, fiel vermutlich im Frühsommer 1944 in? Na?
Rumänien.
Richtig. Da steht doch was zu Fußball.
Zu Fußball steht ja nix.
In seiner aktiven Hobbyfußballerzeit trug Schröder den als Stürmer den Spitznamen Acker, weil er nie aufsteckte und schlussende Augen.
Das heißt, der Kanzler ist daran schuld, dass wir 5 zu 1...
Damit endet dieser Artikel.
Der Rumäne ist schon wirklich......und der Kanzler. Mitternacht im Chaosradio 91. Das Web als Nachschlagewerk bzw. Nachschlagewerke im Web im Besonderen, die Wikipedia und ihr seid wie immer im Blue Moon aufgefordert, hier anzurufen unter 0331 70 97 110. Insbesondere hätten wir ganz gern noch mal ein paar Erfahrungsberichte, also von Leuten, die sich tatsächlich an der Wikipedia beteiligen und das nicht nur sporadisch, wenn sie mal drüber stolpern, sondern da vielleicht sogar so eine gewisse, ja wie soll man es nennen, Lebensaufgabe ist ein bisschen albern, oder?
Wahrscheinlich.
Alle gucken mich an, wahrscheinlich.
Die Motivationen bei Wikipedia mitzumachen sind ja ganz unterschiedlich. Also es gibt ja Leute, die jetzt einfach sozusagen das als Selbstverwirklichung sehen und als Hobby, das denen sie da frönen und es gibt auch andere Leute, die da wirklich sozusagen einen gesellschaftlichen Impact mit auslösen wollen. Ja und das wirklich sozusagen noch das der alten enzyklopädischen Tradition kommen und das als ein Projekt der Aufklärung sehen, ja. Volksaufklärung und versuchen da ein Bewusstsein zu schaffen bei den Leuten.
Beteiligt ihr euch an der Wikipedia 0331 70 97 110? Wie viel kann ich mich denn beteiligen, wenn ich keine Artikel schreiben will?
Du kannst welche korrigieren zum Beispiel. Du kannst schlicht und ergreifend dafür werben natürlich. Aber vor allem das Verbessern von Artikeln ist natürlich ganz hoch im Kurs, weil davon lebt es. Wenn man sich hier mal den IRC-Kanal dazu anschaut, wo die Änderungen sind, da knallen hier alle zwei bis drei Sekunden irgendwelche Korrekturen ein. Und das ist jetzt also nicht alles permanent neue Seiten, sondern in der Regel sind es immer Modifikationen zu Seiten, wo halt was ergänzt wird, korrigiert wird. Das kann jetzt von einfachen Tippfehlern ausgehen, bis hin zu kompletten Formulierungen, Umstellungen, weil man der Meinung ist, dass der Sprachstil nicht ansprechend ist. Je nachdem, wie man sich selber fähig sieht.
Du kannst auch Artikel übersetzen in andere Sprachen.
Zum Beispiel. Oder auch das Interwiki-Lingering herstellen.
Es gibt ein rumänisches wikipedia.org, da findest du den ganzen Quark auch.
Das ist übrigens auch etwas, was teilweise von Bots gemacht wird, aber vor allem auch von Leuten gemacht wird. Wenn man halt eine andere Sprache kann, schaut man eben in der Sprachvariante der Wikipedia nach. Wenn man so einen Artikel sieht und sieht, oh, der hat ja überhaupt keine Verbindung zu einer anderen Sprache, aber ich weiß, das gibt es zum Beispiel in Spanisch. Schaut man in der spanischen Wikipedia nach, sieht, ah, da ist exakt genau derselbe Begriff auch erwähnt. Und durch eine einfache Änderung in beiden Seiten kann man eben von der einen auf die andere Seite sprachraumübergreifend zeigen. Und das wird dann eben auf der Wikipedia-Seite für den Artikel oben und unten eingeblendet, dass es eben diesen Begriff auch in einer anderen Sprache gibt. Das ist vor allem dann hilfreich, wenn man vielleicht zunächst einmal von jemandem auf einer internationalen Mailingliste oder so auf einen bestimmten Begriff, auf der englischen Wikipedia geleitet wird und dann sieht, ah, das gibt es aber auch in Deutsch. So und dann verstehe ich das vielleicht besser. Beziehungsweise, vielleicht stellt man dann auch fest, naja, der deutsche Artikel ist aber im Vergleich zum englischen Artikel eigentlich relativ schwach. Da könnte ich jetzt mal so ein paar Aspekte, die der englische Artikel herausgearbeitet hat, auch noch mit einbringen. Und so wächst das eben langsam.
0331 70 97 110 über Wikipedias reden im Radio mit dem Chaosradio auf Fritz.
Ja, ich hätt meine Frage. Und zwar wird in Wikis hier generell, man kann in Wikis ja bestimmte Versionen aufheben, das wird ja bei Wikipedia auch gemacht, richtig? Alle. Und da würde mich mal interessieren, wie groß ist jetzt der Datenbestand, zum Beispiel für die eWikipedia Org?
Gute Frage.
Also der aktuelle, also der aktuelle, meinst du alles?
Ja.
Da gibt es eine Download-Seite, die steht auch in unserem Dokument drin, wo man sich die gesamte Datenbank als solche, als MySQL-Datenbank runterladen kann.
Mit allen Changes drin? Genau.
Mit allem, genau.
Wo finden wir den?
Ich glaube, das ist unter wikipedia.download, da findest du das.
Ich schaue gerade mal.
download.wikimedia.org, das ist die Webseite, wo das ist. Da sind die sogenannten Raw-Database-Dumps. Der letzte ist vier Tage alt. Die gesamte Wikipedia in Englisch ist 14 Gigabyte groß. Und die aktuelle Version, also sozusagen nur die letzten Versionen, sind 500 Megabyte.
Und das geht ja, das ist ja noch ziemlich klein.
Ja, also passt auf eine Festplatte, aber ist auch schon keine kleine Datei in dem Sinne. Sind auch. Aber es ist halt auch viel Text, wobei, ich glaube das, ich schau hier gerade mal, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob da jetzt schon alle Bilder mit drin sind.
Nee, die Bilder sind nicht mit drin.
Sind nicht mit drin. Okay. Und hier ist auch eine Aufstellung, wie groß die alle sind. Und ich guck grad mal bei DE, Wikipedia Org, aktuelle Version 72 Megabyte, Gesamtbestand 2, 3 Gigabyte.
Das ist ja doch sehr, sehr klein eigentlich noch. Dafür, dass Wikipedia nun doch schon so umfassend ist.
Ja, 84.000 Artikel.
Aber wie viel Text hat der Brockhaus? Eine Seite. Aber der Brockhaus hat, je nachdem, welche Variante man sich jetzt von dem zulegen möchte, zwischen 80.000 und 200.000 Artikel.
Alles klar, danke für deinen Anruf.
Es gibt auch eine schöne Statistikseite unter den Spezialseiten, wo man eben sieht, wie viele Artikel es gerade drin gibt. Und dann auch noch etwas weiterführende Statistiken, die auch ziemlich genau mit schönen Grafiken aufzählen, wie groß auch durchschnittliche Artikel groß sind. Das schleich ich gleich mal nach. Das hab ich nicht im Kopf, aber vielleicht mal kurz, was hier auf der Hauptstatistikseite wiedergegeben ist. Es gibt insgesamt 167.559 Seiten in der Datenbank. Das schließt die Diskussionsseiten, Seiten über die Wikipedia, extrem kurze Artikel, Weiterleitung auf andere Artikel, alles mit ein. Und wenn man diese sonstigen Artikel rauszieht, ist halt der eigentliche Kerndatenbestand derzeit 83.682 Artikel. Und die wurden insgesamt 8, 5 Millionen Mal abgerufen, 1, 3 Millionen Mal bearbeitet. Und daraus ergibt sich 8, 14 Bearbeitungen pro Seite.
Wir hoffen, dass ihr das alles mitgeschrieben habt an euren Radios. Wir kommen danach herum und fragen das ab. 0331 77 91 ist unsere Nummer und angerufen hat Martin aus Berlin. Hallo Martin.
Hallo.
Du schreibst.
Ein Mutiger.
Ja, also ich wollte nur sagen, ich bin jetzt so seit vier Monaten so wikifiziert, oder wie kann man das sagen, wiki-infiziert. Und finde das schon sehr spannend, was da abgeht. Ich fand es auch immer sehr schön, dass man da so korrigieren kann für jemanden, der ein bisschen Oberlehrerhaft ist. Das ist sehr angenehm zu korrigieren, was zu korrigieren ist.
Aber auch zu überbereiben.
Also das fand ich eigentlich immer ganz schön.
Eigentlich und eigentlich? Das klingt wie Kritik.
Ach so, dann streichen wir das eigentlich.
Alles klar.
Was hast du so bearbeitet?
Ja, so alles Mögliche. Einerseits war ich viel zu Südosteuropa, ex-Jugoslawien bei, da hab ich sehr viel in den Artikeln investiert. Zu Thüringen, zum Fahrrad, ja was so ein kommt.
Magst du uns deinen Benutzernamen verraten?
Ja, M-A-Z-B-L-N.
M-A-Z-B-L-N, alles kleingeschrieben?
Das M natürlich groß wie immer hier, bisher.
Der sich sogar schon auf dem Berliner Wikipedia-Nutzer treffen hat, blieb mir außen.
Was ich eigentlich sehr schön finde, ist, das kam ja vorhin auch schon mal zum Ausdruck bei Brockhaus und so, dass das alles so stark kommerzialisiert wird, dass eben hier versucht wird, dass dieser Kommerzialisierung, die man ja auf vielen Internetseiten wiederfindet, ein bisschen entgegenzuarbeiten. Das finde ich eigentlich sehr angenehm.
Das finde ich auch einen sehr wichtigen Punkt, dass die Information, die dort steht, eben nicht Gefahr droht, dass man jetzt irgendwo im halben Jahr dort nochmal draufklicken wird und dann dort eben steht, bitte zahlen Sie irgendwie 60 Cent, wenn Sie diesen Artikel lesen möchten. Das wird eben nicht passieren. Das finde ich auch sehr wichtig, das nochmal zu deutlich zu machen.
Es gab ja leider andere Projekte, wie zum Beispiel die www.cddb-datenbank, also.com ist das, die auch als freies Projekt eigentlich gestartet ist oder beziehungsweise dachte man, dass es ein freies Projekt sei. Und wo auch ganz die Leute sozusagen freiwillig dann, da werden also Tracklisten gesammelt von CDs. Und das dann eingegeben haben und gedacht haben, sie tun da sozusagen der Welt was Gutes und plötzlich kam raus, woops, das ganze Ding wird kommentarisiert und jetzt kannst du da nur noch gegen Bares drauf zu griff haben. Beziehungsweise du kannst auf der Webseite selber sozusagen einzeln die Datenbank durchsuchen, aber du kannst sie nicht im Ganzen runterladen. Und wenn du als Programmierer bist und dein Programm ermöglichen möchtest, da Daten runterzuladen, musst du halt auch Polar abdrücken an der Lizenz.
Martin, du hast, also ich gucke hier gerade mal in deine Benutzer-Historie. Das ist etwas, was auch sehr schön ist. Wenn man den Benutzernamen von jemanden kennt, kann man erstmal auf diese Benutzerseite gehen. Dann gibt es unten so einen schönen Button für Benutzerbeiträge und dann sieht man halt, was hat derjenige geändert. Also Sava von Serbien sehe ich jetzt hier gerade. Hast du irgendwie vor zwei Wochen hinzugefügt? Was ist da dein Bezug gewesen und deine Motivation?
Nee, das hab ich nicht hinzugefügt.
Das hab ich korrigiert bzw. ist das, wenn es hinzugefügt war, ist es aus einer Verschiebung heraus entstanden.
Ah, stimmt. Entschuldigung, ich hab mich getäuscht. Hab ich falsch geguckt?
Ach das noch.
Ja, aber gibt es vielleicht einen Artikel, den du irgendwie gestartet hast? Muss ich jetzt mal ein bisschen weiter zurückblättern.
Gibt's natürlich einige auch, ja.
Und was war so dein Ansatz, da überhaupt dran teilzunehmen?
Also der Ansatz war eigentlich wirklich so die übliche Google-Suche, einfach nach Informationen zu suchen, wie er das am Anfang so schön beschrieben hat. Da bin ich schon vor einem halben Jahr oder länger öfter mal auf Wikipedia gestoßen, aber da gab es ja wohl noch einige Serverprobleme, sodass das Laden der Seiten mitunter sehr lang gedauert hat, dass man doch etwas ungeduldig war und weitergeklickt hat. Aber seitdem, dass diese technischen Grundprobleme wohl im Wesentlichen doch zumindest erst mal gelöst sind, macht es ziemlich Spaß, einerseits wirklich Informationen schneller zu finden, als es über die 4.000 Verbindungen von Google ist. Und außerdem die Verlinkung ist eben auch für meine Begriffe ein ganz besonderer Vorteil, dass man da eben sofort auch wieder sich weiter in der Thematik durcharbeiten kann, ohne wieder neue Suchen stattfinden zu müssen.
Das denke ich ist auch eine Eigenschaft, die so eine Enzyklopädie von einer Suchmaschine deutlich unterscheidet, dass eben das Signal-Rausch-Verhältnis ein komplett anderes ist, dass man dort eben Information findet und eigentlich im Optimalfall null Ballast damit herkommt. Und bei einer Suchmaschine ist es ja eigentlich genau entgegengesetzt, dass man dort einen Begriff sozusagen eingibt und verzweigt in eine 1000 Richtung von den 998 Richter ein.
Das ist eben auch ein direkter Vorteil von Wikipedia, dass man diese Links da hat im Verhältnis zu den anderen Enzyklopedien, die im Netz verfügbar sind. Da hat man die Erklärung zu einem Begriff, vielleicht noch einen oder zwei weiterführende Links, das war es dann aber auch hier, ist alles, was sozusagen im Rand oder von da aus wegführend weitergeht. Also ob ich von dem Datum, von einem Kalenderjahr oder von anderen Orten in der Region oder sonst irgendetwas, kann ich also gleich weitergehen.
Das fehlt ja sonst im Allgemeinen.
Und um sowas zu kriegen, müsste die Endkater ziemlich viel Geld bezahlen, also ziemlich viel Geld bezahlen, um solche Äußerungen zu kriegen. Martin! Hallo Patrick!
Ja, hallo!
Hallo!
Wie zu Tschechien? Ich lese nur, du willst was zu Tschechien sagen.
Ja, ich war in Prag und habe das erste Pagatreffen der Wikipedia organisiert.
Ja, erzähl, wie war's?
Ja, also ich will sagen, ich bin Deutscher, aber mein Vater ist, na ja, sag ich mal aus Kolin und Prag eigentlich. Also Kolin in Tschechien, also Köln auf Deutsch. Und ich bin nach Prag gefahren, um damit den WGpedianern in Kontakt zu schließen und mal mit denen zu bereden, was halt in Tschechien fehlt, warum die Leute nicht schreiben. Das sind 1800 Artikel oder so?
Das ist cz.wikipedia.org?
Leider, ich weiß es nicht, warum es ist.
Und warum schreiben die Leute nicht, die Tschechen? Haben die kein Internet?
Ich hab probiert, das rauszufinden. Ich hab mich mit den Leuten sehr nett unterhalten und ich hab festgestellt, dass sehr viele Leute halt auch irgendwie aus der Tschechischen Republik am Körner mitentwickeln, aber trotzdem nicht in die Wikipedia schreiben.
Und hast du es rausgefunden? Hast du es rausgefunden, warum es so ist?
Nee, also das ist schwierig. Also die haben gesagt, ja, ihr habt viele Medien, so Spiegel oder andere Medien, die das verbreiten. Aber das haben wir halt nicht. Und ich hab halt probiert, mit dem Pragerundfunk Kontakt aufzunehmen und ein deutsches Interview zu geben. Das ist auch zu sehen. Auf der deutschen Wikipedia, wo ich das Interview gegeben habe.
Soll ich mal einen Suchbegriff?
Einfach Patrick Zörner angeben. Und da findest du das Interview, glaube ich, als dritten Hit.
Patrick Zirner?
Zörner, wie Zorn nur mit Bö.
Aber ich glaube, generell kann man das vielleicht als Tipp auch anderen Projekten mit auf den Weg geben. Öffentlichkeitsarbeit ist einfach sehr, sehr, sehr wichtig. Und wenn man nicht irgendwie da ein bisschen hinterher ist, dass man vielleicht ab und zu mal eine Pressemitteilung schreibt und versucht, in die Medien reinzukommen, dann kann es auch sein, dass du ein Projekt ganz lange vor sich hinkriebst, bis es dann mal den Start sozusagen findet. Ja, genau, was ich auch zum Beispiel bei vielen freien Softwareprojekten manchmal bedauerlich finde, wenn man dann auf SourceForge irgendwas ganz Cooles findet und sagt, so ein geiles Projekt irgendwie, aber da entwickeln viel zu wenig Leute dran. Das liegt halt oft daran, dass da zwar Leute sind, die sehr gut programmieren können, aber einfach nicht so hinterher sind, jetzt neu anzuwerben, sondern sich vielleicht darauf verlassen, dass die Leute dann schon irgendwie darauf finden werden, darauf stoßen werden.
Es existiert auch eine gewisse Angst, also zum Beispiel in der tschechischen Wikipedia, da ist Wiet Svanowitz, der ist der Hauptbeteiligte. Und er sagt, es gibt halt zu wenig Administratoren zurzeit. Und ich habe vorgeschlagen, einen großen Rum und Schlag zu machen, halt in der tschechischen Presse. Und daraufhin hat er gemeint, naja, wir können das nicht abfangen. Das könnt ihr vielleicht in der deutschen Wikipedia, aber so wie das heute gelaufen ist mit der deutschen Wikipedia, wo geschrieben worden ist, sofort oder Reverts gemacht worden sind.
Das würde dann nicht funktionieren, ne?
Das wird dann nicht funktionieren. Und deswegen ist es halt mit der Presse da etwas schwierig. Also man muss halt...
Ja, aber keine Angst vor sowas haben, würde ich immer sagen. Also zur Not bleibt halt mal ein Non-Sense-Artikel, vielleicht nicht nur eine Minute oder fünf Minuten wie bei uns stehen, sondern vielleicht auch mal ein Tag. Aber dann durch Forster, dann kann man halt in den nächsten Tagen abarbeiten, was dann an neuen Leuten und neuen Artikeln dazu gekommen ist. Aber generell, keine Angst davor, keine Angst, Pressemitteilung mal zu schreiben, einfach machen.
Ja, das hab ich auch in der Zukunft vor. Ich werd auf jeden Fall mal das BBC, das ist ziemlich aktiv. Und da sind sehr viele junge Leute und interessierte Leute, die das hören. Dieses BBC World in Prag. Das werd ich auf jeden Fall mal kontaktieren. Und wenn ich das nächste Mal in Prag bin, werd ich da auch ein Interview geben auf Englisch. Mein Tschechisches nicht so gut, obwohl das wahrscheinlich überhaupt nichts ausmachen würde. Weil es geht ja einfach nur darum, um die Präsenz da zu wahren. Aber BBC wär halt für mich eine einfache Plattform, um da mal junge Leute anzureuern. Weil die meisten jungen Tschechen können halt da Englisch.
Ja, vielleicht brauchen die dann keinen tschechischen Wikipedia. Vielleicht ist das der Grund.
Doch, die brauchen das. Also das Allerwichtigste ist, da über den Neid abzufahren. Also sozusagen die Tschechen neidisch darauf zu machen, was die Deutschen machen. Weil die Tschechen haben damit ein ziemlich großes Problem.
Obwohl sie uns analog zur Rumänien auch 5 zu 1 geschlagen haben, allerdings im Eishockey.
Ja, okay, die waren dreifacher Weltmeister und einmal Olympiasieger.
Ja, um den Russen eins auszuwischen.
Ja, klar. Und ich bin auch ein ganz großer Vertreter des Eishockey-Teams. Aber die Tschechen haben schon vor dem Brokers, glaube ich, diesen Otto Slobbing geschrieben. Und das ist ein ganz, ganz großes enzyklopädisches Werk. Deswegen werden die Tschechen wahrscheinlich darauf anbeißen wie Piranhas.
Das war gut. So, falls ihr uns hört, Tschechen, wir haben 80.000 Tschechen.
Anstelle von 1.800.
Genau. Patrick, vielen Dank. Und eine gute Nacht. Tschüss. Und Grüße nach München. Hallo Elian.
Grüße aus München.
Du schreibst?
Ja, ich bin Autorin bei der Wikipedia und ab und zu auch Admin. Also sorge in diesem Chaotenhaus ein bisschen für Ordnung.
Mutti.
Ja, eher Gärtnerin.
Gärtnerin.
Warum machst du das?
Ich glaube, man muss ein bisschen verrückt sein, um damit zu machen.
Warum?
Weil es auch eine wahnsinnig nervenaufreibende Tätigkeit sein kann. Die Linken und die Rechten auseinanderhalten und Konflikte regeln und alles. Also das stellen sich viele Leute so vor, als sie an Wikipedia schreiben, an ihren kleinen Artikeln und so vor sich hin. Und urplötzlich stellen sie fest, dass da eine Community dahinter steckt. Und dass sie mit wahnsinnig vielen anderen Leuten in Kontakt sind, das geht auch nicht immer reibungslos ab. Da fliegen durchaus mal die Fetzen.
Gäbs denn so drei wichtige Regeln für den Neuling, der da mitschreibt?
Drei wichtige Regeln?
Bevor er mit der Community kollidiert irgendwie.
Ja generell zu Newbies sind wir eigentlich sehr freundlich. Also das ist ein Grundsatz in der Wikipedia, der heißt Don't Bite the Newbies. Also es werden auch Fehler irgendwie nicht rumgenommen, wenn jemand mal irgendwo was kaputt macht, oder weil er mit der Technik nicht zu rande kommt. Also da ist die Community wahnsinnig hilfreich.
Das kann ich übrigens auch bestätigen. Also ich beschäftige mich auch noch nicht so lange mit der Wikipedia, aber ich habe über die Kanäle, also vor allem über den ERC-Kanal, aber auch über die Mailinglisten eine ziemlich erstaunliche Hilfsbereitschaft vorgefunden. Das ist schon ziemlich bemerkenswert. Man merkt auch schon, dass viele Leute dort zusammenkommen, die nicht alle aus der gleichen Disziplin sind. Jeder hat da so ein bisschen seinen eigenen Ansatz. Der eine ist irgendwie Biologe, der andere ist mehr in Geschichte. Und das trägt schon dazu bei, dass man sich nicht so sehr die Köpfe einrennt. Mein Eindruck. Ich hab gerade mal in deiner Änderungshistorie reingeschaut. Du hast vor dreieinhalb Stunden das letzte Mal was gemacht. Und zwar hast du etwas Wikifiziert. Kannst du das uns vielleicht mal erklären, was das für ein Vorgang ist?
Das ist ein ganz grundlegender Vorgang. Wenn jemand einen Artikel reinstellt, der sich mit Wikis noch nicht so richtig auskennt, dann ist der meistens unformatiert und auch unverlinkt. Und normalerweise geht es sehr schnell, dass jemand diesen Artikel findet und ihn dann eben Wikifiziert. Das heißt, er macht das Stichwort, das Artikel Fett und er verlinkt die wichtigen Begriffe, also das alles in Wikisynthax und passt den Artikel so an, dass er von der Formatierung her gut aussieht.
Bekommst du eigentlich als Administrator jedes Mal eine Nachricht, wenn jemand einen neuen Artikel geschrieben hat?
Nein, das wäre mir auch zu viel.
Ach, 80.000 Mails?
Also, die neuen Artikel kann jeder abrufen. Dafür gibt es eine Spezialseite. Und die gehen Leute auch regelmäßig durch und gucken eben, was es zu wikifizieren gibt. Und was davon Blödsinn ist und wo man was tun muss. Das ist also eine Deck für die Leute, die gerne aufräumen und weiterschreiben an Artikeln und weniger jetzt ständig neue reinstellen. Das ist eine der Hauptquellen.
Es gibt da ja verschiedene Spezialseiten. Also einerseits die neuen Artikel, dann gibt es auch die verwaisten Artikel, die liebte Artikel und gewünschte Artikel. Wo bist du so eher hinterher?
Ich bin eigentlich hauptsächlich hinter den letzten Änderungen her. Das ist die allerwichtigste Spezialseite. Da sieht man, was gerade im Wiki passiert. Alle Änderungen, die jemand gemacht hat. Und das Ganze gibt es auch im Irg.
Entschuldigung, ich im Irg.
Also das kann man sich irgendwie auch live anzeigen lassen, wie das Wiki wächst. Das ist eine ziemlich geniale Erfahrung, als wir zum Beispiel im Februar diesen riesen Medienansturm hatten mit unseren 500.000 Artikeln.
Kann man mal kurz dazu sagen? Das ist auf dem IRC-Server irc.freenode.net der Kanal dirc.wikipedia. Da laufen halt immer alle Änderungen durch. In dem Moment, wo sie stattgefunden haben, kommen die sofort rein. Ich schau hier auch gerade drauf. Sehr schön, gleich mit dem passenden Link. Wenn man da draufklickt, geht im Browser eine Seite auf, wo man die Änderungen sieht. Da kann man halt schön hinterher sein.
Ja, also für Admins ist das ein wunderbares Tool, aber auch für normale Benutzer. Naja, und im Februar ist man da nicht mehr hinterher gekommen. Das ist so schnell durchgesaust, dass der Bot, der das erledigt, vom Server gekickt wurde, wegen Access-Flat.
Und seit wann machst du das?
Und dann war erstmal die Kacke am Dampfen.
Seit wann bist du denn Administrator?
Wie bist denn das geworden?
Das ging damals relativ unproblematisch. Da hat man gefragt und dann haben ein paar Leute gesagt, ja ja, mach ruhig. Und dann hat man einen Entwickler gefragt und gesagt, ich will admin werden und dann wurde einem gratuliert.
So einfach ist das, denke ich, heute nicht mehr?
Nein, also heute ist es vor allem auch für die Leute nicht mehr so überschaubar. Man kennt den an.
Bist du auch Bürokrat?
Nein, Bürokrat bin ich nicht. Da haben wir nur zwei davon. Das erkläre ich gleich, was das ist.
Entschuldige, ich kriege gerade aufs Ohr gesagt. Wir mögen doch bitte mal sagen, wie man die Wikipedia wirklich erreicht. Ganz einfach wikipedia.de, also wikipedia.de. Und jetzt nochmal zum Mitschreiben für die Landwirtschaft. wikipedia.de So, weiter, Elian.
Was ist ein Bürokrat?
Was ist ein Bürokrat? Der Bürokrat wurde eigentlich eingeführt, damit man nicht immer die Entwickler nerven muss, damit sie Admins machen.
Das heißt, ein Bürokrat, er nennt Administratoren.
Ja, er hat die technische Möglichkeit, jemanden zum Admin zu machen.
Und was ist da der Beschlussweg, bis das so stattfindet? Also wenn ich da jetzt hinkomme und sage, hey, ich will aber hier auch mal ein cooler Admin werden.
Genau, dann trägst du dich auf Wikipedia-Admin-Kandidatoren ein. Und dann wird abgestimmt drüber. Also jeder Benutzer kann sagen, ja, nein, aus diesen Gründen nicht, aus diesen Gründen unbedingt. Und je nachdem, wie diese Abstimmung ausgeht, setzt der Bürokrat das dann um. Also der Titel wurde gewählt, damit das niemand werden will. Hat aber nicht funktioniert. Mittlerweile haben wir noch eine Hierarchiestufe. Das ist dann der Stuart, der in der Wikipedia keinen hässlicheren Titel gefunden hat.
Saftschubsen in der Wikipedia?
Was macht denn ein Stuart? Ein Stuart macht Bürokraten, oder?
Ein Stuart kann Bürokraten machen, Admins machen. Also das ist wichtig, vor allem bei kleineren Wikipedias, bei denen das jetzt nicht so organisiert ist wie in der Deutschen. Also zum Beispiel jetzt irgendwie die Maori Wikipedia. Die hat keine Admin, die hat irgendwie vielleicht drei User und dann brauchen sie einen Admin und dann fragen sie den Stuart.
Aber an der Stelle muss man vielleicht doch mal ganz klar sagen, das ist alles nicht so hierarchiemäßig, wie es sich vielleicht jetzt gerade sozusagen für einen Außenstehenden anhört. Also so toll ist es nicht, Admin zu sein oder Bürokrat oder Stuart. Das hast du auch schon gesagt. Genau, du hast ja auch recht. Man kann zwar ein paar Sachen mehr machen, man kann Seiten löschen, man kann Benutzer sperren, aber man darf das nur machen, wenn A entweder der Fall klipp und klar ist, also wenn klar Vandalismus betrieben wird, oder wenn es einen Konsens gibt. Diese Löschkandidatenfunktion sozusagen, wenn man jetzt einen Artikel findet, wo man der Meinung ist, der sollte gelöscht werden, was aber jetzt nicht nur irgendwie so ein Schreibtest ist, so ABCDE, sondern schon ein bisschen Inhalt drin steht, dann muss man den erstmal auf den Löschkandidatenlisten und dann gibt es sieben Tage, in denen sozusagen dann geguckt wird, wird der Artikel verbessert, kann man da noch was dran machen, oder ist der unrettbar? Und genau, und dann kann der am Ende halt gelöscht werden, aber nur wenn Konsens da ist. Also das ist jetzt nicht so eine Geschichte, wo man jetzt in Admin sozusagen selbstheitlich sagen kann, so ja, raus damit, sondern es muss immer einen Konsens geben.
Ja, also im Prinzip sind die admins normale Benutzer mit ein bisschen mehr technisch möglich.
Genau, so kann man das am besten sagen.
Aber sie sollten sich an das Votum der aller Benutzer halten.
Quasi Demokratie. Elian, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Und eine gute Nacht noch.
Wenn Fritz im Berliner Kabel, dann 89, 85.
Mit dem Wetter.
Nachts ist es nur gering bewölkt, die Temperaturen sinken auf 9 bis 5 Grad. Am Tage dann ist es heiter bis wolkig und die Temperaturen steigen auf 23 Grad. Und jetzt gibt es die Meldungen mit Matthias Kerkhoff.
Die US-Luftwürfe hat am Abend der Leutstellungen von Aufständischen in der irakischen Stadt Fallujah angegriffen. Augenzeugen berichteten, dass Munitionslager getroffen worden seien. US-Präsident Bush hat weitere Militäraktionen angekündigt. Der Weltsicherheitsrat hat einstimmig eine Resolution zum Schutz von Anschlägen mit Massenvernichtungswaffen beschlossen. Sie verpflichtet alle UN-Mitgliedstaaten zu gesetzlichen Maßnahmen, damit Terroristen nicht in den Besitz von Massenvernichtungswaffen gelangen können. Israels Staatspräsident Gatslav hat vor einem Wiederaufleben des Antisemitismus gewarnt. Das Thema betreffe nicht nur sein Land, sondern die ganze Welt, sagte Gatslav im Anschluss an ein Treffen mit Bundespräsident Rau. Er forderte die gemäßigten Muslime in Europa auf, sich mit Israel für Toleranz und Frieden einzusetzen. Das Auswärtige Amt hat vor Reisen in den Süden Thailands gewarnt. Dort hat die Polizei den bislang schwersten Unruhen mehr als 100 aufständische Moslems getötet. Die muslimische Minderheit in Thailand fühlt sich von der Regierung diskriminiert. Zum Sport. Die deutsche Fußballnationalmannschaft hat in Bucharest ein Länderspiel gegen Rumänien klar mit 1 zu 5 verloren. Dagegen gewann das Frauenteam in der EM-Qualifikation gegen die Ukraine mit 6 zu 0. Und bei der Eishockey-Weltmeisterschaft gab es für Deutschland die erwartete Niederlage gegen Gastgeber Tschechien. Das Spiel endete 1 zu 5. Der Verkehr auf Fritz hat keine Meldungen.
Vielen Dank, Matthias Kerke, auf 2 Minuten nach halb 1.
Fritz, die großen Sommerfestivals 2004.
Fritz präsentiert das Berlinova-Festival vom 11. bis 13. Das Populario-Festival am 2. und 3. Juli bei Senftenberg. Das Melt-Oben-Air vom 16. bis 18. Juli bei Greven-Heinichen. Das Sonnen-Mund-Sterne-Festival vom 6. bis 8. August bei Saalburg. Die großen Sommerfestivals 2004. Mehr Infos fritz.de und im Radio.
Endsport im Chaosradio 91 auf Fritz. Zum Nachschlagewerk im Web insbesondere die Wikipedia geht es. Erreichbar unter wikipedeia.de wikipedia.de Und ich hab ja eben, das liegt zum einen natürlich daran, dass ich ein grundsätzlich etwas zünftiger Mensch bin, das Wort Ficken in der Wikipedia gefunden und war extrem begeistert. Und zwar nicht, weil ich hab das Wort Ficken gefunden, sondern weil das das erste Mal in meinem Leben ist, dass ich zum Wort Ficken was tatsächlich Wissenswertes lese. Und zwar lese ich aus dem Mittelhochdeutschen Ficken Reiben. Im Althochdeutschen Wichtchitt Juckt. Die ursprüngliche Bedeutung ist schnell hin und her bewegen. Gilt seit dem 16. Jahrhundert als obszön. Großartig.
Ja, ist toll. Ich hatte auch schon vor ein paar Tagen, es ist auch schon mal wieder aufgetaucht, da war das dann einfach ein Riederrecht auf den Geschlechtsverkehr. Das hat dann fünf Minuten gehalten, da war es schon wieder weg. Und es wird jetzt sehr spannend zu sehen, ob das jetzt hier irgendwie sich mal entwickelt. Muss auf jeden Fall noch wikifiziert werden.
Muss noch wikifiziert werden. Ich hab gesagt, ich sei zünftig.
Ja, also wir nähern uns dem Verständnis, aber wer sich dem Verständnis noch nicht genährt hat, scheint die Gemeinde von Schneverdingen gewesen zu sein. Vielleicht magst du das mal vortragen, Holger.
Ja, also es gibt von der Gemeinde Schneverdingen ein, oder über die Gemeinde Schneverdingen, das ist ein staatlich anerkennender Luftkoord in der Lüneburger Heide, einen Eintrag in der Wikipedia und da fand, wer ist denn das hier, der Bürgermeister? Ja, der Bürgermeister von Schneverdingen.
Öffentlichkeitsarbeit irgendwie.
Die hatten da irgendwie Probleme, sie waren nicht ganz mit dem Eintrag einverstanden und haben versucht, den Eintrag in der Wikipedia zu ändern, indem sie an den Kurt, der hier heute Abend in der Studie ist, einen Brief geschrieben haben, betrifft Internet Eintrag. Sehr geehrter Herr, in vorstehender Angelegenheit übersende ich Ihnen beiliegend die Informationsbroschüre der Stadt Schneverdingen. Ich bitte Sie, den vorhandenen Eintrag zu aktualisieren und zu vervollständigen. Für Rückfragen stehe ich Ihnen gerne zur Verfügung. Freundliche Grüße im Auftrag, Corinna Maas. Wer möchte, kann jetzt zum Beispiel bei Corinna Maas in Schneverdingen anrufen und fragen, warum sie denn die Wikipedia nicht begreift.
Es ist doch ganz einfach.
Nein, das ist doch nicht.
Aber natürlich lag im Brief ein Ausdruck unseres Artikels zu Schneverdingen, der jetzt zugegenermaßen nicht besonders umfangreich ist. Und da hatten wir dummerweise wohl unter den Sehenswürdigkeiten das Heiledorf undeloo aufgeführt, was aber da gar nicht hingehört. Da stand also, wurde das durchgeschrieben im Ausdruck und neben dran stand, bitte streichen. Also hat die Mann nicht mitbekommen, dass man das doch hätte selber machen können.
Hast du mit denen mal gesprochen? Was hast du dir dann mal angerufen und gesagt, mach das gefälligst selbst, du Pfeifen?
Nee, hab ich nicht gemacht, ich hab's dann einfach korrigiert und aus.
Aber so begreifen die das doch nie, die Schneeweerding.
Mittlerweile, wie lang ist das her?
Das ist Oktober 03.
Also mittlerweile hat der Eintracht Schneeweerding schon kräftig zu gewonnen.
Ich hab den Knopf in der Mitte gefunden, der Seite bearbeiten heißt und ganz oben steht.
Nein, aber man kann daran halt sehr gut sehen, dass den Leuten das einfach ganz schwer zu vermitteln ist, manchen auf jeden Fall, die vielleicht nicht so internetaffin sind, dass das wirklich geht. Dass man wirklich einfach auch Seite bearbeiten klickt, da was reinschreibt, abspeichert und sozusagen selber im Internet publizieren kann.
Klassischerweise werden seit Erfindung des Buchdrucks Medien ausschließlich konsumiert, also nicht gestaltet.
Genau, und diesen Konsumentencharakter, das mal abzuschreifen, dieses Verhalten irgendwie, das fällt manchen Leuten anscheinend relativ schwer. Oder können sie es einfach nicht kaufen?
Was du ja machst ist, wenn du dir einen Brockhaus kaufst, du gibst ihm ja einen Vertrauensvorschuss. Und in der Wikipedia musst du dir selbst ja auch einen Vertrauensvorschuss geben, in Beziehung auf das Wissen, was du da reinschreibst. Und ich glaube, das fällt vielen Leuten schwer.
Also den Gemeinden auf jeden Fall. Es gibt zum Beispiel auch diesen Problemfall der Wappen. Man ist dazu angehalten, doch bitte auch bei jeder Gemeinde noch das Gemeindewappen hinzuzufügen. Und das ist dann halt manchmal ein bisschen problematisch, weil bestimmte Gemeinden, wie zum Beispiel die Gemeinde Berlin, sich da so Rechte vorbehalten und so weiter. Weil man könnte ja damit auch werben. Dann ist das ja auch schon wieder so.
Und wenn einer schlechte Werbung für Berlin macht, dann ist das ja Senat selbst.
Genau, also die möchten sich sozusagen die schlechte Werbung vorbehalten. Und man ist halt dazu angehalten, die Gemeinde zumindest zu fragen. Das machen dann Leute einfach freiwillig und gehen dann einfach drauf los und sagen, liebe Gemeinde, wir würden gerne das Wappen dort eintragen und ob denn das in Ordnung ist. Und dann wurde das zum Beispiel hier gemacht bei der Gemeinde Schwarzenberg aus dem Erzgebirge nachzuschlagen unter Schwarzenberg, Klammer auf Erzgebirge klammert zu. Und die Gemeinde hat dann auf den Anschrieb auch sehr positiv reagiert. Man hat gesagt, ja, alles überhaupt gar kein Problem. Können Sie gerne machen. Aber wir berechnen eine Bearbeitungsgebühr von 12, 50 Euro.
Bitte was?
Für diese Erlaubnis.
Für die Erlaubnis, weil das ist ja ein behördlicher Akt.
Die haben doch wohl einen Arsch auf, oder?
Musste jemand seine kostbare Zeitverschwendung über den Sessel nehmen?
Das ist ausgerechnet Schwarzenberg sein muss. Der war ja nun wirklich so die einzige nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg weder von den Russen noch den Amerikanern besetzte Gemeinde war, die sozusagen als Lichtgestaltung, Vorbild unter anderem hier auch für das Haus Schwarzenberg in Berlin Mitte gestanden hat. Das ist schon ein bisschen unruhig. Aber klar, sie kennen es nicht und die agieren dann halt einfach noch sehr in ihrem eigenen Ding, anstatt einfach mal selber herzugehen und ihr wissen, was sie in ihrer Gemeinde haben, in der Rauchpause mit dem Browser selber mal einzutragen, weil das kann ja für sie nur gut sein, wenn einfach mal das Richtige über ihre Gemeinde da drin steht.
Ich kenne Gemeinden, die fänden das, glaube ich, gar nicht schön, wenn das Richtige über die da drin steht.
Welche denn zum Beispiel?
Das sag ich jetzt nicht.
Ach so. Was kennst du denn so für Gemeinden?
Man muss übrigens auch gar kein HTML können, um da diese Seiten tatsächlich zu gestalten oder zu ändern. Das geht alles mit völlig normaler schriftlicher Sprache vor sich, mit vielleicht leichten Ausnahmen. Aber technische Vorkenntnisse sind tatsächlich nicht erforderlich. Nur das Lesen der Schrift sollte beherrscht werden.
Ja, ich meine, es wird ja auch dann von Leuten diskriminiert im Zweifelsfall.
Im Zweifelsfall wird hinterher auch getan, aber die sind natürlich bestimmt auch nicht undankbar, wenn man ihnen die Arbeit sozusagen vorher abnimmt, sich da ein bisschen schlau macht und das gleich richtig macht.
Hey, wir haben noch einen Anrufer. Ich kann schon nicht mehr sprechen. Guten Abend, Jakob aus Berlin.
Guten Abend, ich bin Jakob oder nicht dich.
Du bist nicht dich?
Nicht dich, ja.
Ach so, nicht du sozusagen.
Ich wurde hier schon so gedrängt anzurufen aus dem IRC. Ich wollte mal betonen, wie das mit der Community abgeht. Und ich wollte noch mal auf die Qualität eingehen, weil das immer so dieses Argument ist, was kommt, wenn man über die Wikipedia jemanden erzählt, dann kommt da, ne, da kann doch jeder was ändern, das wird doch nix.
Ja, und seltsamerweise sieht es nicht aus wie bei Indymedia, ne?
Ja, dadurch, dass die Sachen ja immer wieder urgänig gemacht werden können. Aber ich denke, da kann man immer drüber diskutieren, wie weit das geht, weil ich hab den Eindruck, wenn man, man muss, irgendwer muss immer hinter den Artikeln her sein. Irgendwer muss sie auf seiner Beobachtungsliste haben, damit sie auch wirklich fachlich gerückt bleiben, weil ich kann natürlich gucken, wenn jemand was Völligenstoß schreibt, aber wenn ich mich mit dem Thema nicht auskenne, dann kann ich nicht sehen, stimmt das nun oder stimmt das nun nicht.
Das wäre dann gleichzeitig ein Plädoyer dafür, fachbezogene Themen auszulagern, aus der Enzyklopädie und die in so einem reinen Wörterbuck zu machen.
Ich denke, irgendwann, wenn das immer mehr weiter wächst, dann wird das so kommen, dass sich irgendein Wissenschafterteam sich ein spezielles Thema annimmt und dann sagt, dieser Artikel, der ist okay und der andere, da können die Wikipedianer erst mal weiter dran arbeiten.
Dann ist es dann noch frei zu halten? Also komplett unkommerziell zu halten?
Frei ist es ja durch die Lizenz. Auch die Wissenschaftler können nichts Schlimmes damit machen, denke ich mal.
Ich meine, das Schlimmste, was passieren könnte, ist, dass die Leute irgendwie angenehm von irgendwelchen unqualifizierten Änderungen sind und sich dann ein eigenes System schaffen, um nur über ihren Fachbereich zu referieren. Aber es wird ja sicherlich kein wirklicher Verlust sein, weil solange das Wissen dort ist und irgendwie erfindbar ist.
Ich denke, wir müssen gar nicht Angst haben, sondern das ist ja einfach eine Bereicherung. Wenn es noch eine Seite gibt, wo nochmal speziell mit Brief und Siegel bestätigt wird, alle Fakten, die in dem Artikel drin stehen, sind korrekt und es sind nichts ausgelassen usw. Ja, schön. Dann hat man noch eine weitere Quelle, die man sich angucken kann und wo man dann, auch wenn da geforkt wird, wie das zum Beispiel bei Software mal heißt, also wenn sozusagen eine Abspaltung stattgefunden hat, kann man ja Sachen wieder reintegrieren, wenn da Sachen zugefügt worden sind, die bei uns jetzt noch fehlen. Also ich sehe das gar nicht so tragisch.
Ja, das war alles, Jakob?
Ja, also es gibt noch viele Möglichkeiten, was man mit den Spielspielern machen kann. Man kann die Daten alles Mögliche weiter bearbeiten und darauf wollte ich noch mal hinweisen.
Was sollte man denn noch mit der Wikipedia machen?
Ähm, mich interessieren wissenschaftliche Untersuchungen über die Wikipedia, also aus soziologischer Sicht. Oder dieses Wachstum, das ist exponentiell, das geht wirklich unglaublich. Und das wundert mich, dass da bisher noch niemand drauf angesprungen ist, weil das so ein interessantes Problem ist.
Das klingt gerade an.
Ja, da sind durchaus schon welche, also wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht in dem Sinne, wie du das jetzt gerade gemeint hast, so als soziale Untersuchung, das finde ich auf jeden Fall auch sehr interessant, aber ja auch in unserem Chaos-Radio-Dokument in der Wikipedia verlinkt ist ein Projekt von IBM, da gibt es so eine, wie hieß das noch gleich?
History Flow.
Ja, History Flow, das hat jetzt gerade nach dem Namen der Gruppe gesucht, wie auch immer. Also wir haben das untersucht und haben so eine Visualisierung der Änderungen von Wikipedia-Artikel gemacht. Sehr schöne Grafiken, wo man so den Zeitverlauf dann farblich hervorgehoben sehen kann, wie ein Artikel angewachsen ist, welcher Inhalt, wohin verrutscht ist, von wem gemacht wurde, wie alt er ist und ähnliche Sachen. Das sagt schon mal eine ganze Menge aus. Da sind ein paar schöne Beispiele dabei, von so Themen, die schon, wie soll ich sagen, immer interessant waren, wie Liebe. Da geht das sehr gleichmäßig und da wird immer mal ein bisschen was dran gemacht und es wächst so ein bisschen. Dann gibt es natürlich so Themen, die deutlich unter Feuer stehen, wie zum Beispiel Irak, wo dann eben mit dem Beginn der Kriege immer der Informationsgehalt auch explosionsartig angestiegen ist.
Kannst du gerade sagen, wo ich es finde?
Na, auf dieser Chaosradio Seite. Ich guck grad noch mal, ob ich die All hier gleich zur Hand habe.
Na nee, wenn es auf der Chaosradio Seite steht, dann...
Tralala. Research, äh, www.research.ibm.com/history. Das ist die Collaborative User Experience Research Group. Und da ist das zu finden. Sehr, sehr schöne Grafiken. Ich weiß nicht, was es sonst noch alles gibt. Es gibt auch gerade im statistischen Bereich schon eine ganze Menge Untersuchungen, auch Vergleiche mit der Aktivität. Wikipedia wird mittlerweile mehr frequentiert als slashdot.org zum Beispiel. Auch eine nicht uninteressante Zahl. Ja, und unsere Anrufe, hast du noch was für uns?
Alles klar, tschüss Jager.
Und noch einen haben wir, hallo Ronny. Willkommen im Radio.
Und zwar wollte ich noch ein paar sagen zur Wikipedia Community. Und zwar, also einerseits, ich weiß nicht, ob es alle kennen, aber es gibt eine Kamelopedia.
Eine was?
Eine Kamelopedia.
Was macht die?
Nur, dass da über ja, ja, Kameda gesprochen wird.
Ausschließlich?
Also die Welt aus der Sicht eines Kamels.
Genau, also ja.
Hast du mal eine Adresse?
Kopfrechnung.
Punkt.de.
Für mir ist keine bessere Domain eingefallen.
Kamelopedia.
Es gibt doch noch kamelopedia.mormo.org. Ich weiß nicht, ob das was mit den Mormonen zu tun ist. Da gibt es schon 254 Artikel.
Das ist mehr als der Tscheche. Nee, der hatte 1800. Aber was haben nur Tet-Kamera mit Kamelen zu tun?
Unglaublich.
Was steht denn da alles drin?
Es gab keine Kamel in der DDR.
Norddeutschland. Guck mal. Bevölkerungsdöner. Was? Bevölkerungsdöner?
Da steht Bevölkerungsdöner. Gleich Vorsauerei.
Oh Tetrapakt.
Ich glaube, das ist im Kontext ganz gut aufgehoben.
Mein lieber Ronny. Was soll das?
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe mal eine Lokalkopie aufgezogen auf meinem Server. Und es hat einfach jemand angefangen, über Kamele zu reden. Und ja, jeder, der auf die Seite gekommen ist, hat auch über Kamele geschrieben.
Ja, es klingt jetzt etwas blöd, aber...
Nein, ich finde das großartig.
Der Server ist nicht besonders schnell, ne?
Kamellistisches Manifest, hört sich auch gut an.
Vielleicht hosten die eben an, drohen mit nach Nebel, dass ich hier an bin.
Gleich mal in Delicious.
Was steht denn da zu Tetrapack? Habt ihr das irgendwie gerade auf dem...
Nee, hat nicht geklappt. Also Tetrapack wollte bei mir auch nicht.
Ja, anderen hört man kurz auf.
Ronny, erzähl mal, was bei Tetrapack steht. Weißt du, was für dich auswendig ist?
Nein, aber es sind keine......eine...
Das ist aber ein guter Ansatz. Mein Lieber, das war wirklich wunderbar so gegen Ende der Sendung, eine Kamelopedia. Hast du noch mehr solcher Sachen gefunden?
Nein, aber ich wollte noch kurz auch sagen, dass von den Designs her bei den Skins noch von Gabriel Wickert, aka Gwicke, bald ein Skin herauskommt.
Für die Kamelopedia? Für die niederwikipedia Software.
Aber im Kameldesign?
Neue Nussinterface. Nein, aus Kamelhaut. Das haben wir doch heute uns angeguckt, überleg doch mal. Das haben wir doch schon gesehen. Haben wir das? Das Nussinterface, das neue Nussinterface.
Das war doch gerade total bei den Kamelen. Ich dachte schon Höcker. Ja, trag das doch bitte noch mit in unsere Seite ein. Genau, da wird nämlich auch die neue, nicht nur ein neues Design, soweit ich weiß, sondern es ist auch die neue Version, die kommende Version 1.3 von dem Media-Wiki, die dort gefahren wird.
Genau, wo man schon mal nach Bugs suchen kann und gucken, ob es noch irgendwelche Fehler gibt, die ausgemerzt werden müssen in der Software.
Genau, da gibt es nämlich dann tolle neue Features, wie zum Beispiel auch ein RSS-Feed für unsere Weblogger. Da draußen und hoffentlich noch weitere lustige Ergänzungen.
Gute Nacht. Haben wir noch was vergessen, Herrschaften?
Oh ja, natürlich haben wir viel vergessen. Es gibt unverständlich unendlich viel zu erzählen. Also Spaß merkt man glaube ich auch, haben die Leute durchaus. Sehr zu empfehlen ist da auch der Wikipedia-Kurier, das Wikipedia-eigene Boulevard-Blatt natürlich auch in der Wikipedia zu finden, wo sozusagen aktuelle Diskussionen aus dem Boulevard-Bereich, zum Beispiel Fotos aus dem Bondage-Bereich, und ob darf man denn das überhaupt machen, diskutiert wird. Was wir auch noch nicht erwähnt haben, was gerade für die Leute, die jetzt so einen Themenschwerpunkt haben und die sich vielleicht nicht von vorne rein in der Wikipedia so recht finden für ihren Bereich. Es gibt diverse Portalseiten, die sozusagen die Sicht aus einem bestimmten Themenbereich eröffnen und dass man ebenso auch leichter an seine Themen heranfindet, die einen vielleicht interessieren mögen. Das ist auf jeden Fall... Also es gibt eine ganze Menge zu finden und wir haben hier sicherlich das Ganze auch nur angerissen. Auf jeden Fall zeigt sich, dass Wikis einen guten Beitrag leisten können, um diese freie Dokumentation von allem Möglichen voranzutreiben. Und das ist natürlich auch wichtig. Ich kann es auch sehr empfehlen für Schulen und Universitäten. Ich habe vor ein paar Wochen ein Media-Wiki-System, also das ist die Software, auf der die Wikipedia basiert, aufgesetzt als kursunterstützende Maßnahme, wo dann die Professoren ankamen. Innerhalb weniger Tage hat sich das eben mit Inhalt gefüllt, wo eben die ganze Dokumentation drin ist, wo dann eben auch die Studenten während des Kurses dort eben das Erarbeitete mit reinbringen können. Und es linkt sich und wird halt automatisch zu brauchbarem Hypertext. Und es ist sehr hilfreich, gerade eben mit dieser Versionskontrolle, mit all diesen Dynamiken, mit die wir gerade gesprochen haben, dass jemand, der sich besser mit dem System auskennt, rübergeht, es reformatiert, aber vielleicht inhaltlich nicht so viel beizuträgt, während die anderen sich eben auf den Inhalt konzentrieren. Dafür kann man eben sehr schöne Sachen machen. Ich rechne mit einer ganzen Menge weiteren Spin-offs, nicht nur zum Thema die Weltaussicht des Kameels, sondern eben auch andere nützliche Sachen, die eben so in der Wikipedia selbst vielleicht nicht unbedingt ihren Raum haben, aber wo die Technologie der Wikipedia ganz praktisch ist.
Also in letzter Zeit hör ich zum Beispiel auch immer öfter, dass Wikis in Unternehmen eingesetzt werden, einfach zum Knowledge-Management intern, vielleicht auch gerade so für Leute, die in einem Unternehmen arbeiten und vielleicht nicht so computeraffin sind, dass die da rangeführt werden können, weil es einfach ein einfaches System ist, wo man nicht HTML lernen muss, sondern wo man wirklich einfach direkt an den Text rangehen kann, Sachen reinschreiben kann, was einem noch fehlt.
Und vor allem sein eigenes Unternehmen mal dokumentieren kann, weil wer blickt denn da schon noch durch?
Alles zu finden unter wikipedia.de, w-i-k-i-p-e-d-i-a.de. Vielen Dank, Kurt. Vielen Dank, viele, vielen Dank, Tim. Das war Chaosradio 91 auf Fritz. Das Thema Nachschlagen im Web, insbesondere in der Wikipedia. Chaosradio 92 gibt's am letzten Mittwoch im Mai. Haben wir schon ein Thema, zufällig?
Natürlich nicht.
IP-Telefonieren? Danke, dass ihr da wart. Danke fürs Zuhören, danke fürs Mitmachen. In der Folge dieser Sendung gibt es den Night Flight mit Martin Petersdorf.